о.в.
у
Доброго дня
вітаємо всіх ми починаємо наш захід в
будь-які присвячений дослідницькими
інфраструктура інтеграції України до
Європейського дослідницького простору
які організований міністерством освіти і
науки і я хочу звернути увагу всіх наших
глядачів що ви можете подивитися пряму
онлайн-трансляцію
українською або Англійською мовою ви
можете перейти сайту Міністерства освіти
і науки за відповідним посиланням і
слідкувати за нашими
Дозвольте сказати
наступне Україна зараз на як дуже
важливих істотних змін і для кожного
українця інтеграція до Європейського
Союзу до долучення до європейських
цінностей це є основною
метою
є основним елементом який
близький до серця кожного з нас І тому
ті Заходи які відбуваються виробляється
міністерством освіти і науки є дуже
важливими для розвитку я з наукової
сфери так інноваційною діяльністю в
нашій країні Дозвольте для відкриття
цього заходу запросити до слова
заступника міністра освіти і науки
України з європейської інтеграції
Олексія шкуратова будь ласка
сьогодні до нашого заходу дуже важливо
для України
присвячено питанню дні науки та
інновацій в Україні і основною метою
даного заходу є підсумовування
результатів
нашої роботи щодо інтеграції української
науки та сфери новації до Європейського
дослідницького простору
важливими завданнями також є обговорення
подальших проектів інтеграції еее 22
роки та подальші роки а також хочу
підкреслити що для України є ваш у І
сьогодні ми підтверджуємо це на
обговоренні різних питань налагодження
комунікації та активізація діалогу з
науковою спільнотою з громадськими
організаціями представниками
інноваційної сфери з представниками
бізнесу щодо
подальшої інтеграції сфері науки та
інновацій до Європейського
дослідницького простору а також це є
підвищення рівня популяризації
результатів наших досягнень в даному
напрямі і при цьому хочу зауважити що І
подякувати нашому уряду за підтримку
Міністерства освіти та науки на шляху до
європейської інтеграції нашої науки та
сфері інновацій також ж хочу відмітити
що незважаючи на оновлену на початку з
цього року дорожньої карти інтеграції
України до Європейського простору
Ми враховуємо так само
активізовано на сьогодні вже
Європейським Союзом новою політики щодо
еее
розвитку науки та інновацій і будемо
звичайно проводити всі заходи щодо
синхронізації наших документів хочу
подякувати нашим колегам з Європейської
комісії за готовність приєднатися до
нашого сьогоднішнього заходу
презентувати нову парадигму
європейського дослідницького простору а
також краще зрозуміти країни асоційовані
країни в тому числі і нашу державу
еее так само хочу зазначити що в
наступному році Міністерство планує
розгорнути системну роботу щодо
наближення до європейської наукової та
інноваційної спільноти зокрема через
розширення участі України в м у
міжнародних європейських програмах ЄС
європейський інновацій і технологій
і
еее продовження
активізація роботи по горизонту Європи
по програмі горизонт Європа і
підсумовуючи хочу побажати сьогодні всім
учасникам плідної роботи цікавих ідей і
за результатами
сьогоднішнього заходу еее Я впевнений що
і Україна і так подальшому буде еее
інтегруватися до Європейського
дослідницького простору дякую о
і
Дякую
що хочу сказати Україна свій шлях до
Європи почала набагато раніше і науковці
як перше які роблять світ новим і
відкритим Вони перші зрозуміли що наука
не має меж що наука це Інтернаціональна
але інтеграція України до Європейського
дослідницького простору ми всі
пам'ятаємо почалася в 2015 році коли
була підписана угода про асоціацію тим
не менше Європа змінюється і Україна теж
змінюється і процес інтеграції це я
неперервний процес і тому я б хотіла
зараз надати слово представнику
Міністерство освіти і науки директорату
з науки та інновацій експерту з
інтеграції до Європейського
дослідницького простору
які розкаже нам про те що було зроблено
І що робиться міністерством освіти і
науки у цьому напрямку будь ласка дякую
не
можна презентацію з о.в.
А я б хотів сказати наступне а
А у 2015 році
після підписання угоди про асоціацію був
прийнятий новий закон Про наукову
науково-технічну діяльність стаття 66
цього закону прямо стверджує про
інтеграцію
науково дослідницького простору України
до Європейського дослідницького простору
з
у у 2018 році
колегії Міністерства освіти і науки
України була затверджена Так звана перша
версія дорожньої карти інтеграції до
Європейського дослідницького простору
цей такий рамковий документ
виконувався декілька років і в 2019 році
було прийнято рішення про
поновлення цього документу оскільки
Європейський союз весь цей час умовно
кажучи не стояв на місці І пропонував
нові ідеї і нові завдання
створена в
о.в.
А я не знаю як в
я була створена робоча група
при національній Раді з питань розвитку
науки і технологій це робоча група номер
3 з назвою євроінтеграція яка більше
року працювала над оновленням дорожньої
карти інтеграції України до
Європейського дослідницького простору
ця робоча група на працювала разом з
активною участю представників
Міністерства освіти і науки України
документ який затверджений наказом
міністерства освіти і науки у лютому
2021 року і про виконання
конкретних кроків цього документу я буду
далі вести мову
А він складається з
А іноді кажуть з 8 пріоритетів як
частіше кажуть шести пріоритетів два з
яких розгалуження окремо на два окремих
і містить конкретні цілі конкретні
завдання та конкретні індикатори в
а
пріоритет 1 підвищення ефективності
національної дослідницької системи що
вдалось Міністерство освіти і науки
України зробити цього року для
досягнення
цілей цього пріоритету
а спершу хотів би сказати про те що було
проведено прогнозних Форсайт не
дослідження з метою затвердження
переліку середньострокових тематичних
напрямів науки техніки та інноваційної
діяльності і урядом нещодавно під
підтримано проект Закону України Про
основні засади формування та реалізації
пріоритетних напрямів наукової
науково-технічної та інноваційної
діяльності в Україні було розроблено
законопроект Про стимулювання діяльності
трансферу технологій що передбачає
фінансування на закордонне патентування
технологій створення за бюджетні кошти в
тому числі за рахунок коштів
державного бюджету на конкурсній основі
в
не було розроблено проект Закону України
Про внесення змін до Закону України Про
наукову і науково-технічну експертизу в
А це перелік законодавчих ініціатив в і
окремо події яка сталася цього року це
Нарешті було підведено перші підсумки і
реалізовано
державна підтримка в
з пріоритетних наукових напрямів
закладах вищої освіти за результатами
проведеної державної атестації і цього
року було укладено 66 договорів
міністерством освіти і науки України
загальний обсяг фінансування яких
становить близько ста мільйонів гривень
в
о.в.
і цього року ми нарешті запустили
конкурс відбору проектів та робіт в
рамках зовнішнього інструменту допомогою
Європейського Союзу цей конкурс вже
стартував листопаді цього року і до 20
грудня приймається
наукові проекти роботи
для фінансування за рахунок коштів так
званий реімбурсації
20-21 році в
по-перше в Україні відбувається
фінансування наукових проектів
національним фондом досліджень України
як думає ви всі знаєте фінансування цих
проектів значно збільшується щороку це є
одним з важливих показників
в тому числі виконання цього ранкового
документу щодо інтеграції до
Європейського дослідницького простору
цього року у нас значно збільшилося
фінансування антарктичних досліджень і
поступово Україна буде виходити на не
тільки антарктичні iraq тичні
дослідження цього року Україна придбала
криголам ноосфера і цей криголам вперше
за більше ніж 20 років наступного 22-го
року спрямує наших дослідників до
антарктичної станції Академік
Вернадський
А
це були такі загальній системі системні
зміни які відбувалися в рамках першого
пріоритету другий пріоритет 2 а
пріоритет спільне вирішення проблем
зумовлених глобальними викликами і деякі
речі які зроблені міністерством освіти і
науки України
про них є в
і головним викликом Так я вважаю для
нашої експертної групи з питань
інтеграції до Європейського
дослідницького простору цього року було
забезпечення приєднання України до
наступної рамкової програми
досліджень та інновацій Європейського
Союзу горизонт Європа
цього року ми провели спочатку три серії
технічних перемовин потім три серії
офіційних перемовин і 12 жовтня В
з 21 року було підписано угоду про
долучення України до рамкової програми
горизонт Європа а також програми з
досліджень та навчання євратом в
а також цього року активного українські
вчені та інноватори долучається до
ініціативи в рамках різного роду
конкурсів
європейського зеленого курсу і
у
Міністерство освіти і науки України на
заклик численних заклик українських
науковців веде
активні консультації активні перемовини
щодо долучення до програми
яка дозволить українським науковцям а
А
як брати участь у спільних заходах з
європейськими колегами так і самим
ініціювати такі заходи в тому числі в
Україні
я сподіваюся 22 році нам вдасться стати
повноправним членом цієї організації
а також ведуться активні консультації з
представництвом європейського інституту
інноваційних технологій щодо приєднання
до відповідних спільнот знань та
інновацій
протягом року була проведена значна
робота аналітична щодо можливості
приєднання до багатосторонніх partners
досліджень та інновацій Європейського
Союзу їх наразі було створено
49 і сподіваюсь після ратифікації
закону України про
долучення України до рамкової програми
горизонт Європа цей процес можна буде
без пауз розпочинати здійснювати в
і цього року ми продовжили участь
України в проекті східного партнерства
яб конект і перейшли до другої стадії
виконання цього проекту я б Конек два
про це Будемо іти далі в рамках окремих
панельних дискусій в
а по пріоритету 2Б оптимальне
використання державних інвестицій у
дослідницькій інфраструктури була
проведена також масштабна робота і воно
продовжується
по-перше було затверджено нарешті
концепцію державної програми розвитку
дослідницьких інфраструктурна 2021 26
роки
міністерством разом з іншими
центральними органами виконавчої влади
було розроблено проект державної
програми розвитку дослідницьких
інфраструктур який наразі узгоджується з
міністерством фінансів України в А
ми закінчили підготовку до запуску
водити дослідницьких інфраструктури в
Україні в рамках інструменту політичної
підтримки програми горизонт і
аудит стартуватиме в січні 2002 року
європейські партнери фінансово
підтримали цей процес є сподіваюсь десь
орієнтовно за місяць в офіційно почуєте
про задачі ознайомитись з командою цього
проекту
і цей процес буде здійснював в а також
закінчено підготовку
також закінчено розпочато процес
створення реєстру дослідницьких
інфраструктур це реєстр містить містить
вже понад чотири тисячі окремих даних
реєстру наразі Є окремим модулем
еее національної науково інформаційної
системи над якої також працює команда
Міністерства
І
наступного року цей реєстр буде
доповнюватись наскільки я пам'ятаю
близько 70 наукових установ та закладів
вищої освіти відгукнулись на наш лист
для пілотування
еее збору і обробки цієї інформації для
створення відповідного кварталу Я
сподіваюся що наступного року кількість
таких установ буде вже вимірювати Сотні
в
А що стосується третього пріоритету
вільного ринку праці дослідників Я б
хотів зазначити ті кроки які стосуються
підтримки молодих вчених в Україні
зокрема проведено цілий ряд конкурсів на
підтримку ідей Та проектів
наукової молоді ці конкурси відбувались
як і відбувається продовжується як в
Міністерстві освіти і науки
безпосередньо так і проводяться
національним фондом
досліджень активно працює Я думаю багато
з вас бачиться активність рада молодих
вчених при Міністерстві освіти і науки
України
цього року
міністерством було розроблено закон Про
наукову науково-технічну діяльність щодо
надання в тому числі державної підтримки
молодим вченим
Ну а також я хотів би відмітити про те
що була прийнята постанова Кабінету
Міністрів України
а в березні цього року про внесення змін
до законодавства щодо покращення умов
для працевлаштування та кар'єрного
зростання молодих вчених
що стосується четвертого пріоритету
гендерної рівності і комплексного
гендерного підходу у сфері науки у сфері
науки то наша частина Міністерство наш
директорат активно підключився до
активностей які
були
в цілому в міністерстві і була створена
робоча група щодо розроблення
методологічних рекомендацій
для проведення гендерного аудиту
закладах вищої освіти та наукових
установах а також була розроблена
концепція міжнародного форуму
присвяченого жінка в науці крім того еее
у нас буде окрема Панельна дискусія Із
залученням компанії і наше Міністерства
готується при у до глобального форуму
рівня організації об'єднаних націй у 22
році який присвячений
успіхам жінкам з тем
у науковій сфері
А
щодо пріоритету 5А трансферу знань та
відкритих інновацій хотів би сказати про
таке
цього року прийнято за нарешті Закон
України Про активізацію діяльності
наукових парків Міністерство розробила
ряд законопроектів сфері інновацій це
базовий законопроект Про підтримку
інноваційної діяльності це законопроект
Про стимулювання трансферу технологій це
законопроект Про внесення змін до
бюджетного кодексу останні два
законопроекти знаходяться вже Верховній
Раді України
еее цього року схвалено план заходів з
реалізації стратегії розвитку
інноваційної діяльності до 2030 року
а
також ми запустили онлайн платформу для
комунікації між учасниками інноваційного
процесу наука для бізнесу презентацію
цієї платформи Ви також побачите
Сьогодні
ми приєднались до глобальної пілотної
програми Організації Об'єднаних Націй
яка спрямована на підтримку Україну
розробці дорожніх карт з реалізації
цілей сталого розвитку за допомогою
науки технологій та інновацій на засадах
Smart спеціалізації цього року ми
делегували представники від України до
форму Європейської навігаційної ради в
і окремо хотів би сказати про пріоритет
5Б що стосується відкрити науки та
цифрових інновацій
орієнтовно в травні ми створили
робочу групу з відкритої науки для
розробки національного плану дій з
впровадження принципів відкритої науки
сьогодні буде відповідна окрема Панельна
дискусія
на якій ми відкриємо карти щодо драфти
цього документу і
сподіваюсь що у 22 році цей національний
план
напрацьований робочою групою буде
представлено на розгляд Кабінету
Міністрів України
також Міністерство проводить масштабну
роботу і те що я вже про це згадував
щодо створення національної електронної
науково інформаційної системи наповнення
її окремих модулів
і ця робота буде продовжуватися
Я думаю десь як мінімум наступні два
роки і окремо про цю систему Ми ще
сьогодні поговоримо в
а
по шостому пріоритету міжнародному
співробітництву ключовими досягненнями
цього року є
прийняття двох законів про відновлення
дії угод Про науково-технологічне
співробітництво з Європейським Союзом та
сполученими штатами Америки
Україна офіційно приєдналася до
реалізації спільного морського порядку
денного для Чорного моря і стратегічної
програми з досліджень та інновацій для
Чорного моря Також я думаю що не могло
залишитися непомітним
прийняття указу президента про розвиток
наукового флоту та морських досліджень
відповідно еее Україна цього року вже
отримала 2А
у
науково-дослідницьких судна для
виконання досліджень
криголам ноосфера при якій вже згадував
і судно Бельгії яка буде
використовуватись нашими колегами з
міністерства природних ресурсів
у Міністерство екології і Міністерство
буде працювати над тим щоб кількість
таких
дослідницьких інфраструктур які можуть
забезпечити проведення досліджень на
морі чи в океані збільшувались
у
декілька слів би хотів сказати про
двостороннє співробітництво України у
сфері науки і технологій в цьому році ви
презентації бачите ті країни які вже з
якими вже Україна зараз має
двостороннє Так звана білатеральна
співробітництва кількість цих країн
буде збільшуватись
у Міністерство працює над тим щоб
у цьому списку
з'явилась умовно кажучи не 12-15 країн а
скажімо
25 найбільших найближчі роки в
А ми профінансували
латеральних
науково-дослідницьких проектів 21 році
на загальну суму більш ніж 17 мільйонів
гривень в
о.в. А що хотів би додати до пріоритетів
впровадження дорожньої карти інтеграції
до Європейського дослідницького простору
22 році окрім того про що я вже сказав
А ну по-перше
заплановано формування пулу експертів
для
українських представників підгрупах
комітету ради Європейського союзу з
питань європейського дослідницького
простору та інновацій iraq
окрім самого національного плану з
відкритою науки
еее Міністерства буде працювати над
запровадженням тих кроків які будуть
запропоновані
Я сподіваюсь Верховна Рада України в
перші 1 або в перші місяці
2022 року і тримає
проект Закону України про ратифікацію
угоди до долучення до горизонту і це
відкриє цілий ряд можливостей для
українських науковців і Новаторів
підприємців цілому для інноваційної
сфери і для реалізації
з цього закону Ми плануємо відкрити
координаційний центр горизонт Європи
програми
запустити і над цим ми вже працюємо
національний портал програми горизонт
Європа
і
оновити та створити нову команду
потужних національних контактних пунктів
які працювали над тим щоб українські
вчені Та інноватори мали Ще кращі успіхи
в
програмі горизонт Європа в
о.в.
А ми плануємо розширити участь України в
програмі як я казав Ми плануємо
долучитись до програми програми до
різного роду можливостей в рамках
європейського інституту інновації
технологій плануємо розвивати морські
антарктичні можливо і арктичні
дослідження в
в
цілому Я
хотів би на цьому великому переліку
завдань як виконаних так і запланованих
на наступний рік закінчити подякувати за
увагу і
попросити всіх
українських науковців і Новаторів
підприємців
а активно долучатись до тих можливостей
які на Сьогодні має Україна в рамках
інтеграції до Європейського
дослідницького простору Дякую
дійсно наскільки багато Міністерство
освіти науки встигла зробити за цей рік
Я розумію що напрацювання були
розроблені ще почнеться 15 року але
дійсно Наскільки я знаю вся Ця процедура
написання укладання дорожньої карти вона
було справді
зроблена по європейського підходу Із
залученням широких верств громадськості
зокрема наукової громадськості І що
приємно фактична Україна іде в унісон з
іншими країнами оскільки таке ж домашні
завдання виконували інші країни які вже
давно є членами ЄС Але тим не менше Є
певні проблеми і відмінність
українського законодавства від
європейського чи є в нашій українських
реалій якісь проблеми з
юридичною реалізацією
у законодавчими перспективами можете
будь ласка
наша наукова активна спільнота
ще починаючи з 2017 року
активно
пропонувала щоб ця дорожня карта була
затверджена на рівні акту Кабінету
Міністрів України
але я думаю що і сподіваюсь що ви
розумієте для того щоб такий як
затвердити необхідно мати відповідне
фінансове підгрунтя і необхідно мати
чітке бачення коли і в якому році нам
вдасться досягнути тих чи інших
конкретних
завдань цій дорожньої карти якщо ви я
сьогодні я говорив десь приблизно про 50
60 тих завдань які зазначені в дорожній
карті про ті завдання які я не говорив
як ви розумієте то вони у або
знаходяться в стані виконання або ми
зараз не маємо людських фінансових чи
інших ресурсів чи Україні Взагалі вони
можливо закриті на сьогодні скільки
училище до наступної рамкових програм і
на цим треба працювати
Тому якщо відверто то
я сподіваюсь що ми маючи
ж таки як Як наказ Міністерства освіти і
науки України будемо здійснювати всі
необхідні активності силами і
фінансовими інструментами які має
Міністерство освіти і науки України
а скажімо Національної академії наук
України будуть долучатись також до
виконання тих чи інших кроків і вони вже
активно долучається в рамках розуміння
важливості тих процесів які прописані в
цій дорожній карті
Дякую за вашу відповідь
дивіться нашу трансляцію буде ще більше
запитань Може ви мені можете сказати А
як наукова громадськість Наукова
спільнота могла б допомогти
виконанні цих завдань Міністерство
можливо
сказав що в
і багато людей багато активних науковців
Ну якщо не щодня як мінімум щотижня
звертається з тими чи іншими ідеями
Можна я вже згадував сьогодні ради
молодих вчених при мон яка об'єднує
широке коло молодих науковців про всій
країні в нас зараз тут аудиторії
знаходиться десятки людей які знову
практично щотижня щомісяця пропонують
свою допомогу для того щоб створити той
чи інший рамковий документ і
Міністерство освіти і науки України в
рамках своїх спроможностей створює
відповідні робочі групи тощо тому так
сказав що якщо ви бачите
резерви часу для того щоб зробити
аналітичний документ
запропонувати конкретні кроки
вивчити ті чи інші інструменти фінансові
юридичні які і вже
реалізовуються чи то в окремих країнах
Європейського Союзу на виконання
спільної спільного бачення спільною
візії яка оновлюється постійно в рамках
активностей
що відбувається в Європейському просторі
та Міністерство відкрите
і
ви можете звертатись безпосередньо
приходити до нас гості писати листи
пропонувати свої кандидатури до
залучення до тих чи інших робочих груп Я
думаю що ми завжди готові спільно
працювати
залишили завершилися час ми маємо йти
далі по нашій програмі Це надзвичайно
важливо і корисно те що робить
Міністерство і особливо приємно
усвідомлювати що зараз підходи робота
Міністерства спрямована відкритість на
співпрацю з громадськістю на майбутнє
дуже вам дякую з вами що ми колеги
Дозвольте на з наступної частини нашої
програми ми всі добре знаємо що
Європа теж змінюється і там приймаються
нові програмні документи і нам дуже
приємно що до цього заходу залучаються
представники Європейського Союзу і ті
зміни які відбуваються в Європі Ми теж
маємо вивчати і
мовчати і вдосконалювати як ви тільки що
почали від пана Григорія Україна
постійно рухається вперед постійно
вдосконалює свої практики базуючись на
досвіді європейських країн і тому ми би
хотіли зараз долучити до дискусії пані Я
сподіваюся що наші технічні помічники
зможуть зробити це онлайн включення чи
готова до нас приєднатися Якщо у нас а й
Доброго дня У нас буде синхронний
переклад Доброго дня пані ми дуже раді
вас вітати на нашому заході Дозвольте
колеги представити
представник генерального директорату з
питань досліджень та інновацій
Європейської комісії
ми знаємо що
стоїть на місці Вона рухається вперед і
нещодавно були прийняті нові законодавчі
акти нові
зокрема був проекту науку та інновацій
ми дуже раді були почути від вас що
нового що останнього Європейської
комісії будь ласка Запрошуємо вас до
слова в
А
я дуже радий з вами сьогодні бути з моєї
сторони також Добрий ранок Добрий день Я
трошки вам розкажу що відбувається у
дослідницькій сфері в Європі і прямо
перейду до своєї презентації як ми вже
сказали є певні
процеси оновлення у дослідницькій сфері
скажу про це трохи
про плани часу він що сталося Які
документи звісно пакт про дослідження та
інновації звісно важливий далі ще один
простір
було затверджено
також було частиною нашої нашого плану
політик впровадження політики і також
процес моніторингу і я розповім про
наступні кроки є ДП європейського
дослідницького простору Отже що таке і
о т я мати єдиний простір для
дослідження інновацій та технологій по
всьому Європейському Союзі з якого могли
б мати щось корисне всі еее країни ЄС і
цей процес розпочався
у
2018 році є ДП як ідея
взагалі існує з
2004 стратегічної мети перше це
пріоритизація інвестицій у дослідження
та інновації
посилення ринку та покращення доступу до
найкращих практик і також посилення
мобільності дослідників та технології
так наступної трошечки історичний огляд
що сталося
Все почалося з того що ми проголосили
нову новий у у 2020 році і був документа
ради які постановив щоб було де
оновлення й
es-3021 році
організували й форум перехідний форум
форум було 12 зустрічей були всі
держави-члени були три воркшопи з усіма
стейкхолдерами і обговорювали такі теми
як управління
а також
політика в рамках є ДП я про це трошки
детальніше розкажу далі і чотири пілотні
проекти зелений
водень пластикові пірати тата платформа
талантів і далі роботи всіх експертних
групах призвели до формування пакту про
дослідження та інновації я це 16 липня
2001 року це
основоположний документ який і грає всі
цінності
якими керуємося у сфері досліджень та
інновацій Європи і недавно Трошки було
перероблено цей документ у листопаді
21 року і було надано нові висновки про
те як має працювати й Якими мають бути
перші кроки
Отже трошки розкажу вам деталі про що
взагалі цей пакти й чотири сфери це
принципи пріоритетні
сфери координація політики
і на цьому слайді ви бачите принципи
якими ми керуємося в сфері досліджень та
інновацій і принципи у свою чергу
розподіляються на такий підгрупи це
цінності
краще краще функціонування та посилення
спільних з а
далі пріоритетні сфери тут зрозуміла
Чого Ми плануємо досягти В наступні
наступні роки це витікає звісно за
цінностей на чим ми хочемо разом
працювати загальна загальноєвропейському
рівні я не буде озвучувати все на цьому
але
тут видно відкриті відкриття наука
координацій інвестиції в дослідження та
інновації
це трансформується у конкретній дії
політичної арджентина наступні кілька
років
і конкретні дії
що ми хочемо досягти
Також у нас є сфера про інвестиції та
реформи то держави-члени підкреслюють що
хочуть досягти рівня 3 відсотки щоб
загальноєвропейського виділялося на
дослідження є і всі
і насправді по
розрізі це може привести до позитивного
результату 1 25 відсотків від зростання
на 11/5 до 2030 року далі моніторинг та
координація
й ініціативи які
спростять моніторинг та координацію між
окремими країнами-членами
ЄС у нас бути платформа для цієї
політики а також звітування на основі 80
місячного й діяльності
навіщо взагалі нове управління є де
потрібно як це буде працювати як ми всі
знаємо змінився контекст у сфері
дослідження є нові стратегічні цілі а
також дослідження та інновації в у до
зеленої та Digital
концепція та інших моральних цілей
політики ми маємо покращити інтерфейси
та спроможності для обміну знаннями у
різноманітних секторах
Ми хочемо під посилити політичну волю
яка буде
виражатися у і більше точкових та
потужних діях
держави партнерами а також більш
серйозне залучення зацікавлених осіб
зацікавлених
дослідження а також полюсі
держави-члени вирішують в яких саме меж
у сферах вони хочуть брати участь
наступні роки ми будемо брати участь у
так званій короткострокові а
також довгостроковий документ який
націлений на 10 років приблизно і а й
спрямування
далі цей пакт спускається рівнем нижче і
виходить проект впровадження координація
політик
звісно все це буде моніторити ми будемо
спостерігати який прогрес ми бачимо і
також нова
і так
на наступні періоди часу критерії дій
Отже ми починаємо з того що ми хочемо
зробити а а А як ми далі організовуємо
управління та діяльність управління
процесом Ми хочемо щоб стейкхолдери були
більш активними цьому процесі не просто
процес держав-членів це просто це має
бути більш потужний структурне залучення
держав-членів
і таким чином буде досягнуто нова
архітектура та нові ролі
яка
виконує політична управління приймає
прийняти
звісно у нас висока роль і rac
простору тобто
виконавча влада
але водночас У нас є нове нова
організація це нова частина наша
структура ЦРУ форум та підгрупи
форум о Я вже всі потенційні підгрупи
будуть частиною цього є Тепер форму і це
організація
відповідає за виконання
плану дій звісно люди будуть залучені
як вже практика показала чудовий
практичний інструмент для досягнення
поставлених цілей
трошечки більше розкажи які будуть цілі
і як цього можна буде досягти на новому
є ДП формі звісно
будуть координації
та
підготовка до є наступні еее 6 місяців
ми будемо обговорювати
20 сфер роботи
[музика]
подивимося які у
і впровадити на рівні держав-членів та
також нерівні асоційованих членів
далі ми спільно створимо план на
майбутнє
відповідних дії це будуть впроваджувати
державні члени і насамкінець аби
завершити цикл політик будемо говорити
про моніторинг та оцінку за де для
опрацювання наступних планів як це буде
досягнете звісно нас буде двосторонній
діалог з державами-членами будемо
обмінюватися
найкращими практиками та структурна
залучати стейкхолдерів у нас буде
платформа яка буде
нам давати можливість впроваджувати ці
найкращі практики і також буде
моніторингова така собі дошка Що
відбувається на рівні кожної з
держав-членів у сфері досліджень та
інновацій
підгрупи
визначених
і далі в
у
Ера форум форум буде продовжувати
інформувати тримати в курсі про свої
політики я говорила про
план політик
можемо
оглядово по-перше ти блакитним в
А це Ті теми які
визначені фактом
тому що ці сфери засновуються на
привітав політики якими наразі хочемо в
яких
розвиватися ви бачите першу і другу
частину Ну дійсно доволі широкий обсяг
сфер над якими буде проводитися робота
те що
рада
визначила певні результати певні цілі
але яким чином ці Результати будуть
досягнути Побачимось ці кроки будуть
зроблені вперше ми побачимо та
проаналізуємо пізніше ці результати тому
що треба підтримувати ті від
держави-члени які хочуть брати участь
існує обов'язкова А
на вирішення кожної держави А на їхній
розсуд і побачимо після цього першого
етапу хто буде продовжувати хто ні на
цій схемі ви бачите як буде виглядати
моніторинговий процес ви бачите дві
платформи А це буде веб-сайт для
взаємодії далі у нас буде такий розгляд
технічний інструмент для моніторингу
того що відбувається в режимі реального
часу
і наскільки це відповідає
індикатором досліджень дослідження
звітність для кожної держави-члена а
також
загальний
річний звіт
і наскільки буде видно наскільки
ефективно впроваджуються взагалі ця
політика перш ніж перейти до питання Я б
ми покажемо Станіслав наші наступні
кроки
ми проводимо новий форум тому що то яким
був минулого року це був перехідний є
форум для експертів і остання зустріч
була у грудні
зараз у нас більш стабільна група яка
також буде включати стейкхолдерів
включати асоційовані держави-члени які
хочуть взяти участі в є ДПС формі і ми
поговоримо про є ДП дії підготовка
оновлених даних про діяльність і
план моніторингу
власне потрібно для того щоб моніторинг
був корисним для країн ЄС та
держав-членів Вибач це з величезний крок
впровадження моніторингу практичне
впровадження запуск цього моніторингу і
це буде приблизно в середині 2000 з
другого року і щоби більше зрозуміли
були
[музика]
зовні це буде аналіз діяльності в якій
бере участь кожна держава-член та
загалом який є вклад у загальний процес
2022 року буде
буде далі переходимо до питань
надзвичайно цікаво і питання таким
чи є
особливе місце для асоційованих країн
так і таких як Україна чи розглядає
Європейська комісія якісь пріоритетні
напрямки співпраці з асоційованими
країнами
і можливо є якісь нові інструменти для
співпраці для поглиблення такої
співпраці в
і
так
асоціація горизонти Європи горизонт
Європи це рамкова програма дослідження
але й це ще ширше
У нас є
звісно вони близько пов'язані з війною
для українців відкритому асоційована але
й
сфери які не повністю фінансовані цією
програмою але
немає спеціалізованого механізму тому що
ви будете у цій у цьому форумі у брати
участь в тому що обсягу яке
держави-члени тому коли ми будемо
говорити про впровадження плану дій
асоційованими державами вони можуть
брати участь і як спостерігачі і якщо
захочуть брати участь нарівні
держав-членів А на а-а-а Чи можу я вас
запитати таке питання як вашої точки
зору що може зробити Україна для того
щоб біль швидко більш інтенсивне
інтегруватися у наступному році до
Європейського дослідницького простору
особливо враховуючи ці зміни які
відбулися європейськими просторі в
а
я думаю буде дуже важливо щоб частин
бути частиною обговорені в рамках форуму
тому що справді
для нас буде Важливо щоб Україна
побачила
що
асоційовані держави абсолютно спокійна
абсолютно вільно можуть обирати в якій
діяльності вони хочуть брати участь і
впроваджувати діяльність лише ті пункти
плану які отримали достатню достатньо
всіх підтримки і для України буде
корисно
поспостерігати
спробувати і поспостерігати в яких
сферах хочеться брати участь
і інформативно як я думаю Міністерства
освіти і науки так і в у української
наукової спільноти ми щиро дякували за
ці кроки як Європейська комісія робить
для розвитку як робити цього
дослідницького простору
таких країн як Україна
сподіваємося що в наступному така
співпраця буде продовжуватися і
посилюватися дуже вам дякую
і це
дуже вам Дякуємо
добре почули що
Україна ім'я освіти і науки багато
робить для запровадження нових
інструментів механізмів деякими з цих
механізмів вже добре відомі наукових
спільнот зокрема такий інструмент як
Cost якому Україна Хоча і не має
постійного членства тим не менше багато
науковці особливо тих науковців які
співпрацюють в прикладній науці
співпрацює з бізнесом і тому особливо
буде цікаво почути про розширення
можливості розширення участі України
саме в таких нових інструментах і зараз
ми хотілося до запросити до слова
координатора програми європейської
програми з науково-технологічного
співробітництва Cost пані каталін Я
сподіваюсь що
зв'язку добро Я
дуже прошу
можете будь ласка нам розповісти про
можливості та перспективи
України участі у програмі
будь ласка Давайте перевіримо зв'язок в
Ми
чуємо добрий бачимо в
Не вмирай до вас вітати на нашому заході
і я тільки що сказала нашим глядачам що
ми з нетерпінням чекаємо інформацію про
те як Україна може долучитися до
програми і ми сподіваємося що ви зможете
нам розповісти про потенційні можливості
для України і вашу точку зору як ми
можемо для цього досягти більш глибокого
співробітництво України в цих напрямках
будь ласка в
у
дякую
Дуже дякую Мене звати Каріна а iPhone
програми європейської програми
науково-технологічного співробітництва
Cost Сьогодні має презентація буде про
код що це таке як
як воно працює і
також я розкажу про бенефіти участі і
про переваги і про іншим моментам перш
за все це
міжвідомча організація зараз Вона
включає 38 учасників
країн-учасників і ці країни вибачиться
на мапі
і
Cost A
і спрямований на
покращення
фінансування на покращення можливості
фінансування
а також надання фінансової спроможності
й тим країнами чиї дослідницькі
можливості
вимагають підтримки
на даним в
а
й три стратегічні пріоритети які
визначають взагалі магістральну
діяльність
це розповсюдження найкращих практик це
підтримка
міждисциплінарного дослідження для
проривних рішень
А це підтримка кар'єр молодих
дослідників
допомагати їм бути лідерами о в
науковому дослідженні в найближчому
майбутньому ми будемо говорити про також
просування та
підтримку найкращих практик це перший
стратегічний пріоритет
проект та діяльність науковців не лише в
Європі А і з їхніми колегами по всьому А
ви бачите на карті що
держави Cost держави-члени це фіолетовий
але партнерство в них розвинені
практично зовсім науковим світом
які географічно близько знаходяться та
мають потенціал співробітництва Це ті
країни де
дослідники не лише запрошуються до
участі але вони мають право на фінансову
підтримку
коли ми говоримо про
стратегічний пріоритет Інтер
дисциплінарно міждисциплінарності
візуалізації зв'язок між різноманітними
сферами діяльності сферами наукового
дослідження й у кіно
по-третє пріоритет про який я сказала на
початку це підтримка та стимулювання
кар'єри молодих дослідників
ми бачимо що
на кожному етапі навчання та розвитку
кар'єри
надається підтримка молодим працівникам
в сфері науки і чому
переваги брати участь у роботі
Звісно це кар'єрні можливості Звісно це
спроможність
довести до кінця певне конкретне
науковий проект чи дослідження це
переваги
переваги для науки
участь у визнанні відомій мережі
науковців
можна пізнати у Полтаві фінансування для
подальших проектів
просування по кар'єрі
буде автоматично відбуватися завдяки
нетворкінгу завдяки знайомству з новими
з колегами у своїй сфері та у сферах
діяльність
дозволяє
підвищувати міжнародну мобільність та
показати свою роботу якомога більшій
кількості і остання але дуже важливо
водночас
допомога
управління допомога у розвитку
лідерських навичок лідерського
підтримки того чи іншого проекту та
покращення адміністративних та
менеджерських
спроможностей і остання але дуже важливо
Я
дуже така вимірювана перевага брати
участь у
якщо
цифра цифра це
то за даними
успіху 37 відсотків ті хто подавалася на
фінансування У двадцять двадцять і брали
участь у діяльності
які фінансує програми в
А що таке axon
akson мережа мережа дослідників та
інноваторів
та їхніх партнерів які беруть участь у
цій мережі тому що цілі і
на
які на які вони налаштовані є
актуальними для всіх учасників
[музика]
відбувається на основі меморандуму про
взаєморозуміння впродовж чотирьох років
і має включати мінімум сім країн
держав-членів Cost
вони не фінансують де саме дослідження
але фінансують координацію дослідження
розбудову спроможностей і 500 тисяч євро
бюджету на цей етап впровадження
Action
пропозицію в
о.в.
у і це має виходити від ініціатора
дослідження подається
проект до дослідницького центру Cost я
первинне первинна пропозиція та вторинна
подавати пропозиції та
інші держави-члени
шляхом голосування приймає ці рішення
про схвалення даного дослідження та
призначаються національні координатори
від кожної країни Дослідники з інших
країн можуть приєднатися до
обговорення такої пропозиції в будь-який
час та на будь-якому етапі Таким чином
взяти участь в
потенціальному дослідження Далі є
мережеві активності які фінансуються в з
бюджету Cost це може бути зустрічі
робочих груп це можуть бути тренінгові
школи
конференції які запрошують держав-членів
або інші держави інших держав це також
можуть бути
й
мобільності
короткострокові можливості для
дослідників та
інші можливості для розповсюдження
інформації та комунікації для публікації
результатів
дослідження в
А
як доєднатися до
костей Action до
програми є три можливості це зробити
по-перше це приєднатися до вже працюючи
це можна знайти на веб-сайті перелік цих
долучитися до робочої групи еее подати
заявку і стати членом цієї робочої групи
у довгостроковій перспективі є ще інші
шляхи до єднання до
еее на короткостроковій основі чи
тимчасово це наприклад
записатися чи бути спікером тренінг
школи воркшопу конференції стати
тренером на якийсь короткий курс чи
семінар або виступити з пропозицією
пропозиції
стати спікером Наприклад якщо ви хочете
самого початку А ти членом
пропонуючи команди
для таких бажаючих розроблено простий
одно кроковий процес подачі своїх заявок
кожного жовтня наступного наступне
очевидно буде жовтні 2022 року в
у і буде відібрано нації про Як деякі
які отримують фінансування і останнє але
дуже важлива також можна стати експертом
з оцінювання заявок
бачите адресу веб-сайту перейти та
побачити список крокос текшин на які ще
приймаються заявки
якості експертом
у тому що це абсолютно онлайн активність
це повністю це цифра оцифрована
діяльність ви можете це зробити з
будь-якої точки країни з будь-якої з
будь-якого регіону світу взагалі а яка
ситуація зараз в Україні з українським
українською участю екшн у поточних
що починаючи з 14 року і до 20 у
більш-менш стабільно з
невеличким падінням ефективності у 19-му
році
19-початку 20 Я думаю це було викликано
початку ми пандемії
то в принципі такий самий тренд є така
тенденція спостерігається і з іншими
державами-членами
близько 35 Action Україна підтримують
Україна бере участь
активним
учасником
мінімум один учасник від України є
відкриті для потенційних бажаючих
учасників з вашої країни варто
задуматися над цими щоб брати участь
основі
впродовж наступного десятиліття яке
почалося і.і. не варто подумати над
формуванням
пропозицій та приєднанням до поточних
робочих груп
як мінімум наступного
року Дуже дякую за вашу увагу рада буде
відповісти на будь-які ваші питання і
і
це дуже цікаво і миті щойно почули від
представника Міністерства освіти і науки
Що Україна збирається
долучитися принаймні робити кроки в
напрямку
повноцінного долучення до програми Чи не
могли б ви розповісти нам про те які це
дає додаткові можливості в порівнянні до
минулого
Чи можете ви додати ще щось до цього в
о.в.
Я
дуже дякую запитання а насправді що можу
сказати
нові держави-члени можуть за можуть
надіслати запит на повне членство якщо
відповідають всім критеріям хороша
новина що приєднуючись до горизонту
двадцять двадцять
окраїна впринципі автоматично всі ці
критерії
виконуватиме ми зараз ведемо перемовини
обговорюємо з міністерствами
які представники Міністерства
будуть подавати запит від України стати
повний на повноцінне членство в
a
Cost
організація розглядає запити і прийме
рішення якщо це рішення буде позитивним
на користь України Україна стане
повноцінним член державою членом Cost
кількість
учасників від України кількість
дослідників з України значно
підвищується Я думаю це буде доволі
це буде чудовим чудова можливість для
українських дослідників в
І
звісно як повноцінне повноправний член
Україна зможе вносити пропозиції про
майбутнє caustics н.е. тобто зможе брати
ініціативу
ініціювати нові наукові програми
від свого імені тобто не просити інші
держави-члени не пропонувати їм
пропонувати безпосередньо від себе і ще
важливо що як повноправний держава-член
в
[музика]
а Україна
з може брати участь в будь-якому
затвердженому
менеджмент управління
[музика]
ефективністю дослідників в
А це цікаво Це фактично дає для
українських науковців можливість і надію
на більш тісне долучення на нові
інструменти і я впевнена що вона
обов'язково їх використовують у повному
обсязі навіть коли країна не є офіційним
повним членом бачимо за статистикою ми
показували наскільки активно Українські
науковці використовують всі можливості
дуже вам дякую за цю презентацію І зараз
я хочу сказати що насправді це не єдина
програма над якою працює Міністерства
добре всім відома програма yorick якою
також науковці і дослідники
інноватори користується проте є
ініціативи нові
зрушення у тому числі в Європейському
Союзі і я би хотіла запросити до слова
програмного координатору напрямку
кластери програми є orico себе у оборона
які розповість нам про оновлену програму
кластерів в програмі і я прошу наших
технічних колег перевірити зв'язок
Доброго дня себастіан
у
Доброго дня дуже з нетерпінням чекаємо
про те які нові можливості є в програмі
будь ласка ми просимо вас до слова О
Я
дуже дякую
спочатку хотів би сказати що
Міністерство освіти і науки а Дуже дякую
вам подякувати вам за організацію цього
заходом це дуже важливим
і
це дуже важливо для багатьох країн
інновації важливим
як ми це кажемо в мережі Евріка і.і.
а а що таке
я розкажу зараз що таке і як можна а
брати участь у цієї програмі
І так
я розкажу також більш Прокласти
юрика і це одна з програм в
у
по-перше що таке
Мені здається що спочатку треба сказати
що таке А
це
міжнародна публічно мережа міжнародного
співробітництва в сфері досліджень
розробок та інновацій а сюди входять
Канада Сінгапур
та іншим
і ми фокусується на розробках
дослідженнях Та інноваціях як я вже
казав і
цілий це забезпечити доступ до
державного фінансування стимулювати
міжнародну співпрацю
прискорити експансію новинки та
запропонувати індивідуальну консультацію
з
у
всього є чотири
ціни і це цілий я вже сказав я зараз я
нам спокусився на кожний з них
забезпечити доступ до державних
компенсування це або це дуже важливо
тому що важливо
забезпечити доступ до офіційних
програм і
раніше
було видалено дуже багато грошей і
також наступна ціль стимулювати
міжнародну співпрацю нам здається що
еврика
це
важливо платформа для цього і програми
Юрій
розвивають нові проекти і також
співпрацю по всіх проектах та у бізнес
стосунки на міжнародному рівні
І
можливо
обмінюватись інформацією
і також підвищити
успіх проектів в
в
ціль А номер три прискорити експансію на
нові ринки в
і
тут головне
головне те щоб учасники
змогли
досліджувати нові ринки за межами Європи
і остання ціль це пропонувати
індивідуальну консультацію
нам здається що це також дуже важливо в
у і
всього є 45 країн єврейка
там є координації і дуже багатий досвід
А що стосуються
міжнародної співпраці
І
звісно вони зможуть надати Україні і
українським дослідникам а дуже багато
інформації
стосовно
програм стосовно
фінансування
і я знаю що в Україні Міністерство
освіти і науки відповідає за цей момент
і так дальше І сіпій що таке кластери
програма кластерів
це довгострокове міжурядова ініціативам
а в ціль
як зробити так щоб
суспільство
працювала над
доданою вартістю
що працювала з бізнесом
і
і працювати на виконання національних
пріоритетів цьому
унікальність програми
аби приводити до балансу державні
пріоритети та органів організації
в чому особливості програми
Я знаю що
слухають
потенційно
бажають дізнатися як покращити свої
дослідницькі потужності за допомогою
підтримка кластерів програм цих
кластерів в
по-перше це
широка тематика дослідницьких тематика
дослідницьких
та потужні екосистеми дослідницької
організації
екосистем це next-generation
communications
ще одна екосистема стосується
інновацій у програмному забезпеченні і
одна про електронні компанії та системи
в
у продовж маківці добре об'єднані
громади
ефективно
тримаються у мережі з
у експертів у кожній зі своїх сфери і
спільно з усіх цих кластерів те що вони
об'єднують малий та середній бізнес
великий бізнес великі організації
також дослідницькі центри університети
академії
тобто абсолютно різну великі
також в
а особливість цієї програми також не
лише у підтримці громада io долучені до
вже існуючих поточних
[музика]
спільні кластери з 2021 року ми
запустили
об'єднання кластерів тобто
змішування представників різних громад
та
надання їм різних
а Інтер Інтер дисциплінарних інновацій
потреби
ринку на навіть найнижчому рівні Звісно
це трошки по-варварськи звучить в
розрізі обговорення інновацій тому що це
щось про
високі технології не про споживацькі
невдоволення споживацьких потреб але
й можливість покрити
потреби та вимоги ринку
і беручи участь в роботі підвищується
свої шанси на подальшу комерційну
активність та успіх
А на основі національних передаю ми
доволі гнучкі ми запускаємо ініціативи
певних країн з тієї чи іншої тематики і
допомагає їм не кидати а цю ініціативу
тому що підтримуються мережею
ще один плюс ще одна перевага це легкий
доступ до малого та середнього бізнесу
хочу підкреслити наскільки це важливо
для громад кластерів
дійсно легко стає
ставати партнерами з малим та середнім
бізнесом з
А
так само Важливо щоб бути
будь-які партнери були
були мали впевненість у тому що мінімум
50 відсотків
фінансування або навіть 60 вже
забезпечено участь у цьому кластері
до певної міри гарантований до певної
міри
впевненість у підтримці це те що дає
перевагу на міжнародному рівні
близька
корпорація з
органами влади
Звісно це спрощує подання проектів і
ефективність і сіпі
також
також можна спостерігати у проектному
менеджменті в у
і це дуже сприяє розвитку
високо
потенційних проектів наукоємних проектів
які матимуть успішні повернення на
вкладені інвестиції в
і для будь-яких потенційних
учасників ви мали середній бізнес
університети в
не маючи пам'ятати що участь в
дає їм знімає з них певну
організаційну напругу ми організовуємо
національними і міжнародними органами
влади та підтримуємо
надаємо підтримку
ініціатором щоб їхня заявка виглядало
максимально успішно отримала максимум
шансів
та впроваджено у
о.в.
І
звісно дослідницька сфера
змінюється кожного року і
ми також дуже гнучкі
і
обираємо ті сфери яким яких ми
підтримуємо проекти тобто якщо проекти є
багато потенціалу то ви можете
подивитися кілька років поспіль і
отримувати фінансування та підтримку
тіста назвав раніше Вони отримують
переваги від доступу до короткострокові
навіть багато доступу до ринку і їхні
прототипи можуть раніше за
конкурентів на ринок і отримати навіть
інвестиції
зацікавлених сторін зацікавлених
в бізнесі
дуже важливо і для країн Це теж тому що
це посилює економічну позиція України по
у порівнянні з в
з інноваційними пріоритетами
порівняно з іншими державами а
І власне це
короткий огляд програми
на цьому слайді ви бачите в
в загальну структуру кластерного
кластерної програми
тут включення національних фінансові
стратегії та національний
Комітет з
[музика]
і діють Вони працюють на основі тих на
основі загальноприйнятих в
Я цілий цілей Та ви бачите на зеленому
тлі
сфери та під організації які є частиною
програми програми кластерів
також важливо зазначити динамічно
співробітництво приватного та
бізнесового
розрізів цієї програми А
якщо
українські наші слухачі мають інтерес до
якоїсь конкретної зі сфери одного з цих
п'яти кластерів ви можете зі мною
зв'язатися
це наступне покоління
захищених комунікацій для людини
цифрових спільнот які є сталими які
можна = =
у
наступний євро
20-30 це
низько вуглецеві енергетичні технології
Idea for це
технологій і програмного забезпечення
для цифрової
транзитом для переходу для
діджиталізації також Smart і
також
переходу
для України до українських стейкхолдерів
є можливість доєднатися до
загальних активностей спільних
активностей
ми працюємо над п'ятьма парами і їх
підготували 10 підтримуючих держав які
ви бачите
Португалія Іспанія Швеція Туреччина
Сполучене Королівство
з наступної запуск спільної ініціативи
лютого 22 року Дякую вам за увагу
відповісти на будь-які ваші питання
надзвичайно цікаво і Наскільки я
зрозуміла з вашої доповіді Українські
науковці теж можуть брати участь всіх
ініціативах Чи не можете ви підказати як
вони мають проявили свою бути активними
що вони мають для цього зробити будь
ласка в
о.в.
у
Дякую запитання і відповідь Так з
Україна може приєднатися Україна є
членом
і Звісно може і в окремому кластері і в
суспільній ініціативі взяти участь
Україна вже бере участь у вже брала
участь у ряді програм не лише в
майбутньому якщо я правильно розумію є
національний університет дослідницькі
центри і окремі компанії які вже беруть
участь у діяльності як взяти участь щоб
український проект
треба відповідати
критеріям в у America їх затвердили 45
країн Якщо хочете отримати
фінансування треба відповідати
критеріями національної національний
програми а дослідження
питання стосовно критеріїв яким має бути
український проект щоб можна було подати
на цю ініціативу можливо можете щось
додати більш детальніше з
о.в.
Я
вибачаюся Я не зрозумів
вони а проекти і Українські науковці теж
можуть подаватися то питання про те яким
критеріям мають задовольняти або
потрапити на цю ініціативу Чи можете ви
підказати українським науковцям нащо
потрібно орієнтуватися в
а-а-а
Я
дуже дякую за на це запитання і я хотів
би сказати що
це критерієм це критерії також критерій
фінансування я б рекомендував щоб
учасники потенційні учасники з України
працювали з міністерством освіти і науки
України
і також працювали з Міжнародним
консультантом міжнародним проектам
координатором є чіткі критерії
і
критеріям перше
а треба що було два незалежних партнерам
з країн
наприклад а університет компанія
інститут
Я з України з
другої країни які відповідають критеріям
другий критерій
а від проекту
мають вигравати всі бенефіціари що це
значить що
щоб не тільки в
у один учасник з
в акції учасники вигравали це два
основні критерії Як бачите
вони не складні
і
також ці критерії можуть відрізнятися в
залежності від
від країн але це два важливі критеріям
інструменти
увагу ще науковців наукових груп до цієї
програми і ми дійсно Будемо бачити
Україну в серед найпотужніших країн які
роблять не тільки дослідження але й
впроваджує інноваційні діяльності дуже
вам дякую Себастьян і далі ми переходимо
до нашого наступного доповідача дослід
А це основне що має турбувати науковця
але без впровадження наукових
результатів досягти економічного
зростання дуже важливо кожній країні і
особливо важливо Це питання для України
і питання про те як інновації мають
співпрацювати як наука має співпрацювати
з бізнесом як впроваджувати наукові
розробки сучасні інноваційні проекти це
питання турбує не тільки Україно це
фактично питання загальну освіту і й
інструменти можливо які не досить
добре відомі в України Але тим не менше
Україна може до них долучатися і тому я
ви хотіла запросити до нашого наступного
до
яка
стратегічних проектів інституту
інновацій і технологій і вона нам
розповість про можливо у спільноти про
те як можна було зокрема українським
науковцям
ну взагалі до майбутніх перспектив
Дуже дякую будь ласка вас
Я
дуже дякую в
а а
а-а-а Всім доброго дня з будапештом
мене звати Діана мудракова
Я Я
працюю європейські інституції інновації
і технології І
сьогодні ми будемо з вами говорити про
інновації в рамках європейської
інститутам я розкажу я розповім про наші
стратегії амбіції і наші досягнення у
о.в.
у
яйці грає ключову роль в тому що
в тому що
і яйці
працює над різними можливостями
майбутнє Європи і залежить від інновації
Нам потрібні нові продукти
на ринку для того щоб залишатися
конкурентоспроможними
і для цього як я вже казала нам потрібно
інновації не вони потрібні для того щоб
ми були конкурентоспроможними
Нам потрібне
правильне середовище а дослідження а
також додаткових знаків у
можливість ми знаємо що для того щоб Для
додаткової
такого фінансування
партнерам потрібно працювати разом і ми
працювали над
цілими що це за елементи студент до
підприємця ідея до продукти і
лабораторії до споживача в
а а у нас є унікальним інноваційне
модуль
і це інтеграція на знань 3
Бізнес дослідження і освіта у нас є
екосистема
і тут залучений капіталісти дослідники і
споживачі в
у
яйці А зараз має вісім
спільнот спільнот інновації і вони
вирішують різні проблеми а такі як
клімат
харчування
урбанізм в
та ін здоров'ям з а іншим енергетикам
і
2022 році а буде розвиток яйці і
ми зможемо
а
налагодити співпрацю і також
підвищити конкретна спроможність
учасників
спростити запровадження нових технологій
та
трансформації та підтримання наступної
генерації наступного покоління
креативних спеціалістів та підвищення
їхніх бізнесових навичок як
далі у 2026 році і
запустить eit Water водний проект який
буде підтримувати водні та морські
екосистеми і буде вирішувати про ми
посух повеней
нестачею води та забруднення води і
циркулярну так звану блакитної економіку
стало економіку в
а горизонт про буде управляти сферою
європейських досліджень та інновацій це
буде покращена можливість підтримувати
ініціативу в рамках в
у
програма
це сфера
Європа європейський горизонт
на основі так званого міждисциплінарного
підходу бюджет приблизно 3 мільярди євро
це 25 більше ніж за попередній період
які дають можливість
втілити амбітні цілі
які було поставлено в рамках і
А ми допомагаємо інноватора мавп втілити
свої ідеї в продукти сервіси послуги та
робочі місця це підтримка нових
поколінь підприємців підтримуємо бізнес
акселератори
та надаємо Smart рішення новим
поколінням підприємців та їхніх амбітних
бізнесового дослідницьких проектів в
о.в.
а
регіональна схема інновацій eit якщо
скорочено
допомога допомога
спеціалізована особиста регіональна
допомога в рамках
європейського плану інновацій
держав Євросоюзу а також а також
асоційовані
до 2027 року
отримали
більшу підтримку
невід'ємною частиною стратегії і
отримали більше для 15 відсотків
фінансування порівняно з попереднім
періодом
підтримка локальної екосистеми
залучення нових партнерів
заснування нових яйця
залучення нових інвестицій у
у діяльність та запровадження нових
дослідницьких стратегій і
[музика]
iga ініціативи підвищення
підприємницьких та бізнесових програм в
установах вищої освіти в
у бізнес освіта в університетах
завдяки ініціативі і буде підтримувати а
установи вищої вищої освіти університету
буде надавати економічну коучинг там
менторство
Університетська активність це
здебільшого у країнах з низьким
потенціалом і новаторства перший
пілотний проект був запущений цього року
у травні 2021 року було обрано 24
проекти
останній
проходить відбір
розпочався 18 листопада
буде обрано в у кілька проектів за
останні 10 років багато чого досягли ми
підтримали понад
проектів які створили понад 1400 нових
нових продуктів та сервісів і
залучили 3 і 9 мільйони
зовнішніх інвестицій
студентів та молодих підприємців в
рамках наших та ігрових програм в
у
кілька з стартапів якими підтримали
перетворилася на величезну історію
успіху перетворилася на так звані
єдинороги вони знайшли стаціонар
мільярди євро
авіація який підтримував якими
підтримували це повністю
перша повністю електричної вертолітна
компанія з вертикальним злетом та
посадкою Норд це
літій-іонні батареї insects інновації
у сфері сільського господарства
у сільському господарстві
та в
у ініціатива у сфері охорони здоров'я та
діагностичної діяльності
більше інформації про можливості та
те що ми робимо як ми робимо
розміщено на нашому вебсайті і itea.ua
також
наших соціальних мережах на всіх
доступних платформах
оперативна
діяльність викладаю інформацію Дякую за
увагу в
і звичайно цікаво і важливо особлива Я
хочу вам сказати що в Україні
відбувається реформені тільки в галузі
науки освіти А у нас наприклад відбулася
дуже важливий потужна реформа
децентралізації і відповідно багато
українських регіонів замислюється над
проблемою Smart спеціалізації і ці
питання які піднімаються формування
інноваційної системи в межах
спеціалізації регіону на рівні регіонів
країни і так далі
кількість українських науковців які
залучені до цих проектів не дуже велика
Як ви думаєте що можна зробити аби
простимулювати таку можливість більш
плідне більш глибокий залучення
українців до проектів є і
до н.е.
Я дуже дякую за запитання так
мами я можу сказати що
Україна не бере дуже активна участь
зараз але зараз своє а нові інструменти
для цього
наприклад мережа ncp і
на в
в університети
також що стосується й
у Міністерство освіти та дукачі України
а
робила кроки в цьому напрямку
на початку ааа і буде робити кроки на
початку 1922 году для того щоб була
співпраця на цьому рівні також
Україна підписала
регіональні схемі роботи
ми на нашому вебсайті
стейкхолдери також можуть обрати тих
партнерів і яйця які
одразу їхню пряму
їхні прямі контакти отримати еее
контактувати з ними
подати спільні проекти з приводу Smart
стратегії і
підхід
конкуренція за місце конкуренція за
місце
тобто
підхід який можна назвати
хочу дуже подякувати за вашу доповіді за
відповіді які надали Я думаю що це
по-перше приверне увагу до цих проектів
які пропонує і взагалі до розбудови
інноваційної системи до якої буде
залучена Україна дуже вам дякую Я
сподіваюся що цей захід які планується
22 році він буде Ще активніше іще
перегар найбільшу вагу То цей проект
дуже вам дякую в
А я хочу сказати що ми зараз почули дуже
багато цікавого і нових проектів і нових
можливості нових програм зокрема ті
зміни які відбуваються Європейської
комісії і
нові перспективи розвитку європейського
дослідницького простору слід Україна і у
нас наступне наше частина засідання
почнеться через деякий час у
12:12 А зараз у нас буде невелика
перерва для тих хто знаходиться зараз
нами в аудиторії можуть залучитися до
наша невеличка пауза а всім глядачам із
Інтернету Бажаю гарно провести цей час і
долучитися до нас через
20-30 хвилин дуже вам дякую чекаємо на
вас наступного частині в
о.в.
а а
у Доброго дня Отже Вітаю Ми продовжуємо
наш
in Ukraine
організовується міністерством освіти і
науки України і зараз ми хочемо
поговорити про дуже важливе аспект який
стосується будь-якого дослідника про
дослідницькі інфраструктури Україна дуже
відома своїми науковим потенціалом
науковими кадрами але найвидатніший
науковець найрозумніший найгарніший йому
потрібне
обладнання на якому він міг працювати І
тому те що зараз робить Міністерство
освіти і науки в напрямку розвитку
дослідницьких інфраструктур це
надзвичайно важливо і я сподіваюсь що ми
скоро дізнаємося про ті напрацювання які
були досягнені за останні декілька років
Міністерство освіти і науки і тому я
хочу запросити до слова представницю
Міністерства пані Прилуцька державного
експерта експертної групи з питань
розвитку науки Міністерства освіти і
науки яка якраз нам і розповість про ті
напрацювання які були зроблені
міністерством у галузі дослідницьких
структур будь ласка пані
Олександра Дякую вам за можливість
виступити хочу почати з презентацією
щодо інноваційних механізмів державної
політики щодо розвитку дослідницької
інфраструктури
почну з перш за все з проблем розвитку
дослідницької інфраструктури які на
сьогоднішній день залишаються незмінними
вже протягом великої кількості років
тому основними проблемами є
незадовільний стан матеріально-технічної
бази наукових установ та закладів вищої
освіти відсутність різних умов праці та
комфортних для роботи приміщень обмежені
можливості використання коштів
спеціального фонду державних наукових
установ та закладів вищої освіти
розбіжності між потребами реального
сектора економіки та можли з наявних
дослідницьких інфраструктур проблеми
забезпечення технічним інженерним
персоналом і для цього для вирішення цих
важливих
і актуальних проблем Міністерство освіти
проводить свою політику формує важливі
документи
але перш за все Я хотіла б все-таки для
тих хто не зовсім орієнтується в
законодавчій термінології визначити
поняття дослідницька інфраструктури які
є в цьому законі на сьогоднішній день це
сукупність засобів ресурсів та
пов'язаних з ними послуг які
використовуються науковим
співтовариством для проведення
досліджень на найвищому рівні що охоплює
об'єкти наукового устаткування та
обладнання або набори приладів ресурсів
що базується на знаннях колекції архиви
депозитарій або банки даних наукової
інформації інфраструктуру засноване
технологій комунікацій Грід комп'ютери
програмне забезпечення мереж зв'язок та
інші структури унікального характеру
пані Олександро ви пам'ятаєте ми з вами
працювали над важливим документом це
внесені у до Закону України Про
інноваційну Про наукову та
науково-технічну діяльність і
почали з того що все ж таки має
відбутися нормування унормування
термінології відповідно до українського
законодавства з врахуванням
європейського законодавства
Європейського Союзу оскільки в законі
України окрім термінології дослідницька
інфраструктура є ще термін державна
дослідницька інфраструктура треба
розуміти ключові відмінності цих двох
термінів перший термін полягає в тому що
дослідницька інфраструктура це загально
як я вже сказала сукупність засобів
ресурсів і послуг і дослідницькі
інфраструктури відповідно до
Європейського Союзу можуть бути локально
розташованими віртуальними або
розподіленими тобто по суті це така
мережа ресурсів і вони бувають
приватними або державними
дослідницькі інфраструктури можуть
входити до міжнародних мереж
в українському законі було і прийнято
рішення в 15-му році що необхідно ввести
термін державна дослідницька
інфраструктура якого в Європейському
Союзі немає і під державною дослідницько
інфраструктурою розумілися об'єднання
наукових установ та або вищих навчальних
закладів державної форми власності що
створюються з метою оптимального
використання їх ресурсів
еее
збереження банків даних і знань та
координації їх ефективного використання
для проведення наукових та наукових
досліджень але ми розуміємо що такі
дослідження вони призводять до певного
асоціативного ряду і треба зрозуміти все
ж таки в рамках українського
законодавства що яким чином ця
інфраструктура має відповідати нашому
нашим вимогам до нашої нормативну
проектованої техніки тому ми почали
працювати спільно з робочої групи
Національної Ради з питань науки та
технологій в а над таким важливим
документом як зміни до Закону України
Про наукову і науково-технічну
діяльність щодо питання дослідницька
інфраструктури цілому взагалі Це питання
мало бути першим Але у 20-му році
Президентом України було прийнято указ
номер 210 в якому було зазначено що
повинна бути розроблена державна
програма розвитку науково-дослідної
інфраструктури і вже контексті прийняття
цього указу Міністерство почало
працювати над важливим стратегічним
документом як концепція державної
цільової програми розвитку дослідницьких
інфраструктурне періоду 26 року чому
саме дослідницьких інфраструктура не
науково-дослідна інфраструктури тому що
ми все ж таки намагались привести у
відповідність до Європейського
законодавства цю еее назву цього акту і
в рамках
виконання
концепції мала бути розроблена
національна дорожня карта розвитку
дослідницьких
а в нашому законодавстві це називається
державна цільова програма розвитку
дослідницьких інфраструктур
та концепції державної цільової програми
полягає в тому що має бути створено
необхідні організаційні правові та
фінансові умови для розвитку системи
дослідницьких інфраструктури в Україні
Підвищення їх конкурентоспроможності а
також розвитку сфер наукової
науково-технічної та інноваційної
діяльності в частині доступу вчених до
передових дослідницьких інфраструктури
Європейського Союзу на сьогоднішній день
ця концепція прийнята вона прийнята
розпорядженням 322 від 14 квітня 21 року
на сьогоднішній день Міністерство освіти
і науки працює над самою програмою
проектом програми державної цільової
державної цільової програми розвитку
дослідницької інфраструктур ключові
етапи реалізації цієї програми наведені
на слайді це удосконалення механізму
державної підтримки
організаційно-правових форм дослідницька
інфраструктури цей день у цій
інвентарізації систематизація
дослідницьких інфраструктур це
забезпечення розроблення та реалізації
порядку формування переліку
дослідницьких інфраструктур державного
значення це розроблення фінансових
інструментів підтримки дослідницьких
інфраструктур протягом певного життєвого
циклу сприяння множинності джерел
фінансування українських дослідницькі
інфраструктур і останнє це формування
міжнародних зв'язків з європейськими
дослідницькими інфраструктура ми про які
ми поговоримо дещо пізніше і в контексті
цієї програми мають бути враховані
ключові принципи роботи відкритих
дослідницьких інфраструктур Це перша
регламент доступу визнання та співак
юридична відповідальність витрати та
збори етична поведінка
недискримінація управління даними
досліджень демократизації інструкція
користувача тобто якщо
інфраструктура потрапляє в певний
перелік який буде розроблено пізніше
після прийняття цієї програми то вона
має у і виконувати та дотримуватись цих
принципів для того щоби бути релевантною
дослідницьку інфраструктурою
Європейського Союзу
Також ми
заклали основні терміни парадигми
відкритою науки сьогодні про це теж
будуть говорити декілька слів скажу що
це загальнодоступність наукових даних
отриманих за рахунок державних коштів це
можливість доступу та повторного
використання всіх наукових даних без
обмежень кордонами та напрямками
наукових досліджень це рівні можливості
та правила учасників для всіх для всіх
учасників і остання що я хотіла би зараз
сказати це на яких принципах має
відбуватися розвиток дослідницької
інфраструктури взагалі в цілому в що при
формуванні державної політики це перше
концентрація дослідницько інфраструктури
та людських ресурсів за напрямами
наукової науки відповідно до викликів
суспільства це збереження академічною у
порядності як базові цінності під час
реалізації політики відповідно до
державних пріоритетів це реалізація
принципів відкрито науки про які ми
говорили це оптимізація майна державної
дослідницької інфраструктури виключно
для збереження цілей розвитку наукової
сфери і це виокремлення функцій з
управління майном та визначення
пріоритетів наукової діяльності
Дякую вам за увагу якщо є питання будь
ласка я
це надзвичайно важливо і цікаво і я хочу
сказати що те що ми зараз почули і в
першій частині нашої дискусії коли
представник Європейської комісії
озвучувати такі слова як відкрита наука
доступ даних так далі ми бачимо що
дійсно Україна йдеш називається нас і ми
можна сказати майже не відстаємо від
єврейської спільноти І можна навіть так
сказати що українська Наукова сфера вже
інтегрована з цьому контексті І от на
питання які ви підняли про розвиток
дослідницьких структур я не можна задати
питання від цих науковців
чи передбачається фінансування цільова
програма Про яку ви розповідали
імплементувати всю цю політику можливо
за рахунок саме фінансових інструментів
будь ласка Якщо можете Дуже дякую вам за
це питання це дійсно важливо і на
сьогоднішній день Міністерства освіти і
науки здійснює перемовини з
міністерством фінансів ми розуміємо що у
нас є ключовий гравець який розподіляє
кошти державного бюджету визначає
пріоритети тому еее що силах
Міністерство освіти науки ми робимо всі
зусилля які докладаємо до того щоб
мінфіном узгодити додаткову потребу на
виділена таких коштів на розвиток та
форма розвитку дослідницької
інфраструктури а тому я думаю що в а
найближчим часом стане відмов відомо
результати таких перемовин І що нам
скаже Мінфін тому що насправді тільки
він може прийняти
кроки для того щоб покращити цю сферу
Дуже дякую Я думаю Прошу пробачення я
думаю що наше спільне завдання
досягти найкращих результатів для
розвитку наукової освітньої сфери і ми
науковці стоїмо пліч-о-пліч
міністерством освіти і науки і будемо
намагатися підтримувати вас всіх
прагненням дуже вам дякую за ту роботу
яку ви проводити і зараз дякую пані
Ірина І зараз я хочу запросити до слова
нашого нашого спікера з
європейська
дослідницька інфраструктури Доброго дня
пані Орнела ornella
Вітаю вас
Ми вас ми бачимо
Добрий день дуже дякую
виконавчого директора цей рік
Прошу розповісти нам про
інтеграцію в європейське дослідницьких
структур Я думаю що можливо в Україні
мало хто чув Але тим не менше це відома
асоціація прошу Орленок будь ласка вашу
презентацію
і з нетерпінням чекаємо в
Я
дуже дякую Що запросили нас і вітаю
Україну
за чудовий прогрес який ви робите
просування до Європейського
дослідницького простору
Отже окрім
дослідницько інфраструктура відіграє
ключову роль в науковій інтеграції
України
з точки зору користувачів
тих хто дійсно користується цією
інфраструктурою Ми бачили і я про це ще
буде говорити що коли ви організується
колаборації на
Європейському і міжнародному рівнях в
а
буквально миттєво відбувається
розширення бази користувачів
у це інвестують у специфічні тренінги
інструменти що може зробити що може вам
надати цю інфраструктура і в плані
підготовки
заявок і процес доступу
вимагає заявок а потім обрання з цих
заявок
часто буває так що
Наукова частина чудова виконала але
заявка оформлена правильно і в цьому й
проблема і ваші дослідницькі
інфраструктура через колаборації з
Європейським консорціумом чи іншою
міжнародною структурою
через інфраструктури
і працюють в рамках принципу відкритого
доступу та справедливого відбору І це
дає можливість
більш
прозорі і більш якісні результати
відбору
отримувати під це підвищення звісно
якості публікації та кількості
публікацій що відповідають заданим
критеріям
інфраструктури дослідження вашої країні
що можна про них сказати до єднання до
консорціуму буде надзвичайно для них
корисно тому що
науковці з міжнародної спільноти зможуть
звали напряму працювати
що ви отримаєте натомість найкращі
практики найкращі знання про ту чи іншу
сферу про що йдеться
у дослідженні
також можете створювати колаборації з
колегами з інших країн регіонів
спільне фінансування
для науковців професорів організаторів
дослідження
якщо у вас хороша мережа хороший
нетворкінг то вас можливо запросять у
запрошують до участі у споріднених
сферах це теж корисно також можете брати
участь у існуючі інфраструктурі не лише
у Європейському консорціум а також і в
інших європейських дослідницьких
інфраструктура
членству в консорціуми відкриває вам
цілий ряд нових можливостей
вигідних можливостей
нетворкінг у
вас також буде
право голосу правосл а визначати
стратегічні програми
у нас також є спільні навчальні програми
доктора ти то що Ви також можете
приєднатися до
європейської дослідницької
інфраструктура будемо скорочено на рік і
приєднання до неї має бути рішення з
боку уряду з боку урядових структур
ще важливо
говорити тут про інвестиції тому що
дослідницька інфраструктура вимагає
амбіційних інвестицій на початковому
етапі це пов'язано з ризиками дійсно в
а
підтримати запуск певної
на найвищому рівні інакше
Європі його діяльність засновується на
документів
ради
Європейської ради
підпорядковуються всі держави-члени
для тих країн які не є членами
Європейського Союзу
Вони мають написати листа і там
прописати таким шаблоном що така-то
держава повністю визнає юридичну
[музика]
лідерство Ерік та організаційне
лідерство а готова на ваших умовах
наумов
єднатися до діяльності у цьому тобто
така документальне підтвердження того що
ви готові підкорювати ся
[музика]
правила спільноти та діяти у
відповідності з ними
також стосується процесів публічних
закупівель а також погоджуєтеся що
і важливо знати що слизу регулятор
може також встановлювати
свої
нові додаткові правила для затвердження
нових членів тобто можливо
розвитку дослідницьких дослідником
інфраструктури на сході Європи у нас
зараз з держав-членів вісім і ми
інвестує
у розвиток інфраструктуру у сусідніх
країнах
на 50
додаткових інструментів і ми працюємо
розробили сервіси у нам дисциплінарному
рівні досліджень тобто
матеріали про
технології нанотехнології ми Багато
дослідників цікавляться і
спеціалізуються на енергетиці зокрема
стадії енергетиці
інфраструктурне
інфраструктурного розвитку
продовжувати дослідження енергетику як
таку
що
на кожну країну одна установа від
консорціуму і
у кожної країни унікальний свій внесок
на підтримку загальної інфраструктури
обов'язковий внесок
і це єдина зобов'язання яке поки що має
країна яка хоче залишатися членом
консорціуму
можна може податися будь-яка країна
важливо сказати що для
індивідуальних для фізичних осіб доступ
до інфраструктури має бути безкоштовним
та держава яка стала для своїх громадян
забезпечує
безкоштовне доступ до
науково-дослідницької інфраструктури
штаб-квартира знаходиться
в Північній Італії і
дослідження в
І ми також отримали фінансування від
Європейської комісії є ко фінансування
через проект oxalate для ми ми
розробили дуже ефективно колаборації з
України і цей проект триватиме чотири
роки
і
наша мета посилити наукове
співробітництво з Україною та прибрати
бар'єри які не дають українським
науковцям доступу до нашого європейських
деяких українських
дослідницьких установ
інфраструктурних об'єктів і
а
також частиною нашого плану
було заснування штаб-квартири
r.a. Тобто це підтримання людськими
ресурсами для тренінгів під час в
університеті університеті було
проведено на базі на матеріальній базі
низки українських університетів в
а також ширше тренінги з людських
ресурсів
теж були проведені загалом
було організовано ряд Network
заходів
також навчали майбутніх працівників
системи
консорціуму ПРО
лідерських навичок менеджера Ми також
намагалися покрити максимум зацікавлених
осіб максимум працівників сфери
науки та організації на 50 відсотків
учасників які ми заходів які ми
організували в рамках проекту
були з цього цих центральних заходів які
організовували в Україні
проекти було запущено у червні
продовжувати цю спів у цьому Ми вже
бачили
як різні українські дослідники
долучаються до наших проектів буквально
два дні як ми запускаємо проекти
українці одразу долучаються це приємно
бачити і ми розглядаємо як
абсолютно
[музика]
впевнений Крок вперед в Ужгороді
наприклад була був центром була зустрічі
фасилітаційна центру
який
діє
в рамках магістрального напрямку Комфорт
в Україні
але звісно все це вимагає значних
інвестицій тому якщо Україна стає
членами консорціуму
потрібно інвестувати
в розбудову інфраструктури в Україні яка
б допомагала в Україні
і науковцям
комітет
що нові держави-члени консер цьому в
а а можуть вважатися
повноправними членами якщо впродовж
першого року
надають
доводять світі дійсно ефективна вкладу
діяльність
працівників
представників України Буде Буде надана
можливість поговорити з
особисто Зустріч або он-лайн зустріч з
представниками центру
спостерігали з Україною з іншими ми
бачимо на цьому слайді блакитними
стовпчиками це процент заявників з
України
порівняно з загальним загальною
кількістю заявників із 2017 року ми
бачимо що всі ці
у
тренінги
на них процент українських учасників
вище зростав цю чудовий знак це чудовий
а
червоні стовпчики це кількість скільки
загалом
заявників
виявилися успішними і Скільки з них були
українські
доволі позитивну тенденцію весь час
підвищення зростання
Отже
чудової процес 2020 році звісно через
Ковель була певне падіння
тому що багато об'єктів інфраструктури
було зачинено просто фізично не було
можливості
далі
можливо нам треба працювати з більш
спеціалізованими установами які будуть
не так сильно і
я тати під
обмеження
пов'язані з будь-якими надзвичайними
ситуаціями такі
приєднання України до Комфорт
абсолютно реально тому що це відкрита
організації і україна має право
надіслати свою заявку Україні нічого не
заважає
взяти участь у нашій роботі проте
набагато
прискорює
темпи роботи
наукові інфраструктурі і конкурентність
росте навіть на локальному рівні до
цього треба бути готовими в
а а членство у консорціуми відкриє цілу
низку можливостей
допоможе отримати доступ до всіх
інфраструктурних інструментів на
Європейському рівні І також установи
дослідницькі стануть більш поважними та
потужними центрами розвитку науки та
досліджень
яке неможливе без
зовнішніх факторів
буде доступ до
технологій
методології а також до зовнішнього
фінансування
ви станете більш
вас буде бачити більша кількість людей
тобто еее
у підвищиться і в
у і можливість інфраструктурного
розвитку
інколи
наші партнери наприклад не зможуть взяти
участь з вами
розуму Напевно є
дослідження з низки причин але вони
зможуть допомогти інших партнерів
тобто напризволяще
ніхто не покине також
відкриті будуть українських вчених тобто
фактично повністю інфраструктура
відкрите для держави члену який
більшої мобільності
методології результатів досліджень це
призведе до позитивних тенденцій як
підвищення довіри до науки як такої
найбільше інфраструктури у Європі
це
наша Ми намагаємося брати участь у
європейській
відкритого відкритої науки Open склад і
наступного року планується продовжувати
з моєї сторони це фактично якщо є
будь-які питання ради відповісти
дуже цікаво інформативно і дійсно ми
побачили з вашої презентації що
повноцінне членство в рік це рік
інфраструктури дуже багато можливостей я
хотіла вас запитати таке питання можливе
могли б дати якусь пораду українським
науковцям Що потрібно зробити для того
щоб або певна Наукова група або центри
колективного користування обладнанням
які
долучитися знайти собі таких партнерів
що ви могли порадити о.в.
з
точки зору наукових груп Я думаю я
зрозуміла ви маєте на увазі групи
які мають достатньо інфраструктуру аби
приєднатися до консорціуму зазвичай
зв'язки створюються
на основі
[музика]
університетів та тем які вже тривало
мають історію співробітництва конкретної
проблематики і ми саме з цього виходили
у створенні колаборації і
з чого можна
досягти
навіть якщо ви досягли максимально
можливого рівня залучення як це
далеко не те у Гоа що вам відкривається
коли ви стаєте державою членом Це
очевидно людський ресурс доступ до якого
відкривається абсолютно не ним не
порівнянне тобто справа не лише у
людському ресурсі але наскільки добре
освічені науковці наскільки добре Вони
володіють
дослідницькими інфраструктурне
інструментарієм
Тому
колаборації це добре
Дуже дякую за вашу доповідь і зараз ми
хочемо запросити пана Василя Який теж
приєднається до нас в онлайн форматі
розповісти про свій досвід
як у нього отцеві і сталося і тому
Дозвольте мені представити нашу до
наступного доповідача це завідувач
кафедрою твердотільні електроники та
інформаційної безпеки Ужгородського
національного університету
Василь як я сказала Він розповість нам
про досвід співпраці у Європейському
консорціум
будь ласка очікуємо
появу пана Василя в онлайн-режимі
його презентацію зараз він з'явиться
Я сподіваюсь що досвід українських
науковців які вже мали можливість
працювати в Широкому спектрі
дослідницьких структур буде для нас всіх
дуже важливим і корисним Тим більше що в
А як Нам сказала пані Орнелла не це не
просто доєднатися до дослідницьких
структури це обов'язково має бути певна
процедура і крім того це питання яке
пов'язана з фінансуванням наскільки
розуміли зараз у нас
доброго дня ми бачимо вас Я так розумію
що відбулася невеличка технічна затримка
яку ми зараз швидко виправимо в
А чи налагодилося у нас зв'язок
і
будь ласка давайте запросимо спікера до
мікрофону до його презентації в
Ми
вітаємо вас а.а.
а-а-а був безпеки неї я буду говорити в
а а
зараз може нас відбувається синхронний
переклад тому пан Василь якщо хоче може
безпосередньо робити свою презентацію
українською мовою і всі слухачі
залежності від мови вони зможуть
прослухати його презентація або
Українська англійської мови в перекладі
тому не буде У нас цим проблема але як
ви вважаєте за потрібне Так ми будемо
просуватися в
у
декалекс
по-перше Дуже дякую за цю можливість
презентувати результати роботи нашої
команди а
ти і я буду відповідати від ім'я нашої
команди в
а
ми всі брати участь в створенні цієї
презентації
декілька слів що стосуються
створення лабораторії один дерматол н
професор в
з університету в Празі в
я
був одним з співзасновників
цієї лабораторії і в нього була мрія
відкрити цього прозорою
співпраці з
цією світлині
[музика]
було дуже важко сказати Ні цієї
пропозиції і Володимир смоланка Ми також
співпрацювали поїхали і
зустрічі на генеральної асамблеї і
нам здалося що у Європі не очікував
такого потужного університету і
була підписана угода
між нашими
організаціями і.і. і
ми почали працювати з з
у Європейський науковцями
Так тут інформація стосовно рік
і ми не будемо зупинятися на всіх
слайдах і ми перейдемо до проекту
Я хочу нагадати що це була а.а.
у наш час
праця
тобто Хто брав участь
європейської організації і наш
університет
і
була підписана угода а між нашої команди
європейської організації
для того щоб взяти участь у програмі
брали участь
Італія Німеччина
інші в у
пакети проекту
включають в себе
різні структури а потім і
і на залучення нових учасників
розвиток інфраструктури відкриття нових
центрів та впровадження результатів
проекту
наш проект б
і
має на меті довготривалу сталість
інфраструктура законодавчої ініціативи є
Які посилять прозорість
дослідницьких структур також розробка
методології для
вимірювання
соціально-економічного впливу
досліджень
та тренінгів для користувачів в
у вчених одним
проекту було впровадження
інфраструктурного центру акселерати в
Україні
Тут допомогла кафедра
фізики та електроніки інформаційної
безпеки Ужгородського національного
університету
завдяки цьому Ми можемо працювати на
сучасному обладнанні
достойним європейській дослідницьких
університетів тобто доступ до
обладнання та інфраструктурою майже
необмежений
дослідження взаємодії
поверхнею оксиду титану з
і тут я в
а по цих слайдах пройдуть лише мимохідь
в
о.в.
у
результаті досліджень
ми дізналися природу мікроскопічного
механізму взаємодії
з поверхнею
оксиду титану
однак згідно з попереднім аналізом
ми дійшли до не дуже приємного до
висновку
кореляція між
зв'язками молекули оксиду титану
але впродовж роботи Ми отримали безліч
позитивних емоцій ми у нас було багато
поїздок до європейських інституцій
і окремо отримали оновлене
обладнання з
а тут це список
новинних сайтів в інтернет які написали
про успіх
фото
національному університеті та церемонію
нагородження надання
поважного професора метою за активну
участь у міжнародній Науковій співпраці
ми підготували кімнату місце простір для
нового обладнання і ми бачимо процес
налаштування
обладнання в
для
створення
Ого спектрометр у магнетрон ної в
о.в. у
електронного аналізу в
о.в.
у
і заключний звіт про як туа
акселератор
підкреслює підтримку
найкращим партнерам в Україні і ми
знаємо що аби залишатися актуальними в
науковій сфері треба знайти свою нішу
дослідження
та техніки технології доступні
Ми з представниками
особливо з чеськими коли ми проводимо
аналіз
сфер діяльності і як результат
пропонуємо в у
організувати Форпост лабораторії з
відновлюваними джерелами енергії в
Ужгороді в
А ми покращуємо своє по-новому своє
обладнання не зробимо
центром інфраструктури в Україні ні
сподіваємося що це допоможе Україні
стати членом церкви в
у
та забезпечити активну роботу в
лабораторії
ми забезпечуємо
сучасне обладнання
моделі в
і
дифракційне обладнання для
диференціювання
для сканування та мікроскопи
сили
завдяки яким можна досліджувати атоми
Отже в
і
це також допоможе нам отримати
відповідне фінансування саме на цю мету
оновлення обладнання
і
нашій основні фасадні лабораторіями
також буде подаватися на
обладнання сонячними лабораторіями у нас
була структурна структурна реорганізація
в
а
можливо ще й
І
рано говорити але ми також
планували і дослідження з синхронної
радіації що буде дуже цікаво і
європейськими українським дослідникам
які працюють в сфері
Прикладного вивчення матеріалів
нашу заплановану
заплановане дослідження лежить У рамках
національної економічної стратегії 20-30
європейських цілий
зеленої Ого ти
стосовно акредитації
Ми сподіваємось що наявність такого
обладнання і
о.в.
у буде схвалено міжнародним науковим
комітетом Ми дуже вдячні
заступнику міністра європейської
інтеграції Олексію
та виконавчому директору
за
їхні інтереси надзвичайно підтримку Дуже
дякую за увагу будь ласка питання Дякую
це надзвичайно цікаво і важливо що ми
всі побачили що насправді в українських
університетах наукових установах є
обладнання яке використовується для
сучасних досліджень і є можливість для
наукових груп долучитися до європейських
інфраструктур і можлива коротке питання
З чого починали якщо ви можете
відповісти в
о.в.
і
ми почали 20 років тому в
А
коли наші студенти
стали їздити з візитами до європейських
університетів в
а
досвід Ужгородського університету і
після цього заходу думаю команда отримує
дуже багато запитань яким чином це можна
досягти І хочу сказати що не Українські
науковці працюють не тільки в
інженерних Вибачте
дослідницьких які базуються на
обладнанні але також Україна відома свої
ID галузі те що зараз слово
діджиталізація вже не вимагає перекладу
українською мовою всі дуже добре знаємо
і мені б хотілося запросити до слова
старшого спеціаліста з наукової роботи
мережі junt
Кріса
Я сподіваюсь що він
щоб він розповів нам про можливості
підтримка світових наукових спільнот
саме войти і
будь ласка Вітаю Кріс в
і
Ми з нетерпінням чекаємо
щоб ви ж
Ми
представили які є можливості для
українських науковців можливо також про
якісь питання спільної роботи співпраці
з Україною будь ласка в
я
дуже-дуже дякую
ти
така Мене звати Кріса спеціаліст
наукової роботи мережі
і сьогодні я буду говорити з вами про
асоціацію жарт в
у м
о.в.
А я ж ти
і так повною планую
хвилинку будь ласка в
Я
так думаю що зараз це працює Я починаємо
і так Важливо почати з того хто ми є і
у
асоціація жарт с колаборация
європейських національних дослідницьких
та освітніх мереж
Ми підтримуємо розвиток досліджень
освіти та інновації у глобальному
масштабі
разом Ми створюємо інформаційну систему
інфраструктур і послуг і вони
використовуються для зв'язку співпраці
обміну даними та доступи до сховищ
сервісів та засобів і
I
am витоки ж Ант А це гають перших днів
інтернетом
у
Але зараз я хотів би сказати що ж
я ж МВЦ організація
[музика]
у якої є 40 мереж учасників з Європи і
всього
мамина підтримуємо
так 10000
закладів
Так я казав що
вже з перших днів інтернетом
і
так наприкінці 80-х початку 90-х
виникла потреба перенести дані
досліджень із це
Дякую за те що правили слайд Так я казав
а це був на
на кордоні Франції і Швейцарії і
потрібно було за даними досліджень із
цим до них користувачів по всієї Європі
та США Росії та Індії
наприкінці 80-х початку 90-х років
європейське Академічна мережа було
створено співпраці з національними
дослідницькими та освіти мережами на той
час
тобто
якщо з'єднати всі
університети на державні агенції то
трималася та мережа
А чому чому нам потрібні спеціально
мережа для досліджень та освіти в
у
відповідь в тому що я різниця як
як будуються
Академічна мережа
і для
комерційної мережі в
I
am дані які проходять через мережу вони
Пони як хвиля
велика
велика і маленька Це залежить від
від години
і
2017 році файл розміром 100 Треба був
передам
до
Австралії
і ми в
ми
закупили а дві
комерційних
мережі
швидкість була гігабіт в секунду для
комерційної мережі це було добре але це
було недостатньо для нас і
А
що тут потрібно сказати що
де того щоб ці дані
дошли до
Австралії а
там були
там було не так все гладко і
в мережі
ж ми
змогли досягти швидкості 10 хабіб в
секунду і це
близько до того що ми
обіцяли а
у тобто дані змогли дойти з женеви до
канберри
а швидше
якщо порівняти це з комерційною мережею
про що це говорить що а й потреба на
академічну мережу і на швидкість
академічними режим для роботи тому що
всім нам
потрібно інтернет для того щоб ми могли
обмінюватись даними в Я і так в
а а
зараз
46 країн в А ти ж об'єднує ці 46 країн в
а
з іншим світом в
А
у нас достатня швидкість і також
декілька гігабіт них
з'єднань
і
швидкість терабайт в секунду в нашої
мережі
Також ми працюємо з багатьма
дослідницькими організаціями в
в-во ЄС і в інших країнах
нас є партнери а
у
глобально ж
і в Африці базі а
з Північної та Південної Америки
і ми наша ціль це розвивати науку
глобальна
таких проектів
які релевантний для України називається
проект iconnect зараз він другому етапи
десять з половиною мільйони дев'яносто
п'ять відсотків фінансування ЄС від
дівчини
re5 відсотків
це внески учасників країн-учасниць
і Україна це одна з таких країн
Ціль проекту
з'єднати країни в
I
am в академічних цілях
це проект
що складається також
проект що складається з співробітників
європейських національних
науково-освітніх мереж та організації
тобто я сам працюю в проекції що зараз
ми зараз разом ми розвиваємо послуги
необхідне дослідникам для виконання
їхньої роботи
а для того щоб можна було передавати
великі масиви даних
глобальним
і приклад за станом і я сподіваюся що
він дасть вам уявлення про вплив які
може мати підключення до цієї мережі
по-перше
адже сайті чому це важливо ми
використовуємо для ви у трьох глобальних
проблем катастрофи та реагування на
надзвичайні ситуації сталий розвиток та
зміна клімату це глобальна вирішується
політичними структурами
Сендай Framework наприклад Паризька
кліматична угода А
17 цілей сталого розвитку ООН і нам
потрібно
на це потрібно того щоб розуміти що
що коїться і.і.
у
Тобто нам потрібні дані щоб розуміти що
перевірити що відбувається існує область
яка називається спостереження за землею
і ми допомагаємо
перемістити даних спостережень землі з
джерел даних до дослідницьких груп які
виконують аналіз і одними з таких
прикладів є приміщення даних а до та з
ЄС і mwf
і її
відстежує зміни клімату в рамках проекту
з
о.в.
і
так тобто
с проект
декілька мільярдів там є супутники в
космосі і Дані відкритим в
у
і всі можуть
їх використовувати
також
ще з
1997 року а як світова спільнота
ми погодилися що змінна середня
температура поверхні є результатом
викиди в антропогенного фактору тобто і
це має прямий вплив на такі речі як
висота рівня моря що загрожує а
країнам як Мальдіви Нідерланди або
будь-якому місті з узбережжям Все це
впливає на те що ми залишаємо нашим
майбутнім поколінням не тільки на
макрорівні але і на мікро він також так
а це а світлини З
у мережі Коперника тут ми бачимо а
оксид азоту
і ми бачимо
ми бачимо
так Так
можемо побачити звідки находять викиди з
часом це дозволяє дослідникам вимірювати
вплив
державних рішень і обмін цими даними
стає можливим дослідниками завдяки нашим
мережі наприклад 85 користувачів даних
ЄС підключених інфраструктурне і решта
користувачів отримує через комерційний
інтернет в
у
дані отримані сателітами копернікус
допомагають у дослідженні землетрусів
морського життя атмосфери і прогнозу
погоди А зміни використанні землі
а також стали сільське господарство
зміна клімату це все в зоні уваги
і приклад того як це може бути
використано в Україні
надає членам
пряме підключення до наборах даних
програми спостереження за землею
копернікус це Ісаія
і це підтримує не лише дослідження але й
надає можливості для малого та
середнього бізнесу і це дуже цінно
співпраця
i-size ю.в.
о.в.
і так
зліва дані від копернікус передані через
нашої мережі і вони використовуються
країнами навколо Чорного моря в і
так на зображеннях показані сезонні
антициклон
циклони в морі
так
системи
яка є спільною місцю на
ринку навколишнього середовища
копернікус Марін вона використовується
дослідниками для визначення сезонних
течій на основі цього вони можуть
консультувати уряд підприємства щодо
політики та маршрутів суду сплав ства в
у і
тобто
морські судноплавні компанії що працюють
у Чорному морі можуть оптимізувати
планування свого проходу зменшуючи
використання палива та витрати на
доставку
також уряд та підприємства можуть
приймати кращі рішення та сприяти
зменшенню антропогенних викидів та зміни
клімату це приклад того як ми
безпосередньо допомогли можемо
використовувати копернікус
і зараз ми збираємося надсилати даних
щоб
у нас була можливість подолати ці
виклики три виклики
Так це буде здійснювати через Нову
віртуальну приватну мережу яка
координуються між jrj tiret Клара
і
завдяки цьому
А ми можемо нам відправляти сотні Гб
даних
4.2
Також у нас є окремий канал тільки для
копернікус
дані
в Греції це
там розташовано один з центрів
копернікус
і початковий результат в
а збільшення пропускної здатності та
зменшення затримок від нових
трансатлантичних з'єднань побудованих
John Deere
є
багатообіцяюче
і ця можливість є крокової зміну для
Латинської Америки та досліджень які
тепер можна проводити завдяки покращеним
підключенню nahrin
і
тобто
зараз глобальний дослідники можуть
обробляти ці великі дані
і не тільки зараз але й майбутньому і
і так і кабель била що він означає що
дослідникам буде безперешкодно
регіональна в них буде безперешкодно
регіональна та міжконтинентальних
інфраструктура яка з'єднує їх джерелом
даних це принесе користь будь-якої
установі яка підключено до їхньої
національної науково-освітньої мережі на
тільки латинської Америці Але й в
Україні так
ааа тут
зображення і ви можете завантажити
мою презентацію ми нотатки
так
приходить до це європейська гравітаційна
обсерваторія під назвою
і вона розташовано в Італії в
О
так це місця підключення до локальної
мережі
і він також використовує службу а
дозволяє дослідникам використовуйте одно
ім'я користувача та пароль для доступу
до всіх Ви платформ і дослідницьких
служб які підключені до нього інакше
відомий як єдиний вхід це система
вимагає що університети то встанови що
беруть участь
керували своїми власними користувачами
але це зменшує навантаження на
дослідницькі проекти та співпрацю це
полегшує дослідницькі проекти з іншими
регіонами світу
університетам науково-дослідним
інститутом він надає доступ до ширшого
спектру послуг ніж на
місцевому чи на національному рівні у і
після створення не буде додаткового
адміністративного навантаження на
інститут який надає ідентифікація
повертаючись до вірго
станом на лютий 2021 року до співпраці
входять понад
650 членів які представляють 119 установ
у 14 різних країнах
і приклад
дуже-дуже
Можливо але я не може утриматися не
задати вам одне дуже коротке питання
Скажіть будь ласка що ви думаєте
чи можуть Українські науковці за рахунок
долучення до мережі робите якісь нові
цифрові якісь нові і цифрові сервіси що
дуже зараз популярна в
і
я думаю що найкращим найкращі ідеєю буде
поговорити з
українською
дослідження та дослідницького ситуацію у
них потужності у них зв'язки
переміг тому що знайшли а також з
глобальним світовим дослідницьким
що презентацію яку ви нам представили
буде можливість ще й продивитися і
глянути Які ще можливості дає для
українських науковців і для залучення їх
до міжнародних європейських наукових
інфраструктур і ви згадали в своєму
своїй доповіді проекті of конект А у нас
в аудиторії якраз є представник цього
проекту який може а розповісти Більше
про це із вашого дозволу Я би хотіла
представити нашого наступного доповідача
я би надала зараз слова Євген у
преображенському виконавчому директору
асоціації уран про його досвід участі в
проекті
і розповісти про те що саме
вже доступно українським науковцям
України уже та
України уже та виконавця проекту в
і спочатку декілька слів про нашу
організацію
статус України тобто статус національної
дослідницької освітньої мережі не це
скорочення від англійського терміну
надаємо доступ до високошвидкісних
каналів junt і пропонуємо унікальний
цифрові послуги розроблено спеціально
для науки і освіти А все це неприбуткова
організація
засновниками якої є вищі навчальні
заклади України четвертого рівня
акредитації установ Національної
академії наук та академії педагогічних
наук України це членська організація і
сьогоднішній день вона нараховує 83
члени вона відкрита для прийому нових
учасників будь-які інститут чи
університет будь-яка Наукова установа
може подати заяву до радості і стати її
членом а отже впливати на її роботу
а
мережа уран є частиною національної erg
інфраструктури тобто ресурсу ран
включено до списку національних ресурсів
розвитку і інфраструктур Європи іржі ми
брали участь у створенні концепції
розвитку українських дослідницьких
інфраструктур що була затверджена урядом
у квітні цього року Як бачите завдяки
участь у міжнародних проектах зокрема
Україна має широкі можливості
ідентифікації свою науки і освіти в
Європейський дослідницький
інфраструктури та для скорочення
цифрового
Дозвольте розповісти як саме це
можливості використовуються такі
перспективи вони надають з нашим
науковцям та освітянам з
у
важливий напрямок діяльності надання
доступу до високошвидкісних каналів без
якого деякі дослідницькі проекти були б
неможливі прикладом такого проекту є
робота відділу експериментальних
досліджень фізики елементарних частинок
ядерної фізики високих енергій у
національному науковому центрі
Харківський фізико-технічний інститут це
єдиний український колектив що обробляє
дані від великого Дону від
багатоцільового експерименту з
компактним неоном серединою
дані курсують відкрито мережевому
середовищі Великого адронного колайдера
скорочений і доступ до цього середовища
відбувається через мережу Жан
отримує доступ до
ємністю 10 гігабіт в секунду і вже
відчуває потреба розширити канал
приблизно до гігабіт на секунду
оскільки потік у них необхідно зростає
він зросте ще більше після модернізації
колайдера яку планує закінчити у 2028
році
обчислювальний комплекс Т2
залишатися одним з найкращих
інформаційно-обчислювальних рідних
і підтримувати репутацію України на
міжнародне наукове арені уран має
потенційно змогу підключати ннц хфті на
дуже великій швидкості до Стахіва біт на
секунду
довгі приклад використання каналів з
користю для України стосується проекта
що Київський політехнічний інститут
імені Ігоря Сікорського
подав на конкурсний відбір до
Міністерства освіти і науки
науково-технічної проект з розробки
методології та програмно-апаратного
комплексу для моніторингу і аналізу
кліматичних змін на основі супутникових
даних і у метеосат в і використання
результатів цього в проекту сприятиме
сталому розвитку економіки країни
розвитку території та захисту критичної
інфраструктури умовах підвищеного
екологічного навантаження та критичних
змін клімату для впровадження проекту
знадобиться служба багато
від європейської організації з
експлуатація метеорологічних супутників
перекус згадував своє доповіді крім
даних майже в режимі реального часу на
станції прийому користувачі потребують
до цього потужних каналі вже
доступних Київська політехніка зможу
отримати від Уралу в
о.в.
А
крім доступу до високошвидкісних каналів
пропонує унікальний цифрові послуги що є
стандартом для науки освіти в Європі це
захищений viro Ми відвідали можливість
безперешкодного підключення до Інтернету
незалежно від того переміщується закладу
чи навчаєтесь працюєте в чужий
науково-освітні установі десятки тисяч
точок доступу до відділом і більш ніж у
ста країнах світу Україна також є у
цьому списку іду гель це способ
авторизація які використовує технологію
єдиного входу та дозволяє користувачам
науково-освітніх закладів отримувати
доступ до освітніх наукових ресурсів за
допомогою одного облікового запису які
видає користувачу його домашню установу
новообраного Європі як єдину систему
авторизація студентів та працівників
університету в приймаючих участь у
програмі еразмус плюс з за допомогою
Євген вже зараз Європі втілюються
реалізації електронного студентського
квитка та програми еразмус плюс
захист даних розроблений спеціально для
науки освіти надійний навіть при
використанні безкоштовного WiFi в
громадських місцях
авторизацію відбувається за допомогою
Великого обсягу
Google Диск або вони не захист
конфіденційних даних і не підтверджують
справжність особи яка ці дані
натомість
персона яка розмістила Данте завжди один
фіксована через а дані завжди захищений
in академія надає можливість студентам
працівникам установ отримувати доступ до
онлайн-сервісів або купувати їх за
спецій з умовами при цьому захищає
особисте даних користувачів
дозволяє продавцю
на академічне знижки та послуги для
цього використовується обліковий запис
клієнта в системі
виступа я згадував що цього року став
частиною інфраструктури Жан це відбулося
завдяки запуску в рамках проекту
двох нових каналів Кишинів Київ та
київ-познань які розширює європейську
мережу Жан та підвищувати стратегічне
значення нашої країни для
нових з'єднання завершує півкільце
Бухарест Кишинів київ-познань і включає
першу регіональну лінію зв'язку між
двома країнами східного партнерства в у
на ділянки кишені в Київ та київ-познань
мають здатність 100 гігабіт в секунду
зафіксований безпрецедентним контрактом
про невід'ємного права на користування
на 15 років ціни та технології
залишатимуться незмінними навіть після
закінчення проекту
нава інфраструктура використовує
передову спектральну технологію яка
забезпечує передачу ще більшого потоку
даних за допомогою різної довжини
світлових хвиль і тому нові ділянки
теоретично зможемо передавати дані на
швидкість і близько чотирьохсот гігабіт
в секунду просто шляхом оновлення
модулів передачі саме завдяки цим
каналами зможемо на дуже великий
швидкістю підключати до
науково-дослідні установи на кшталт ннц
хфті астрономічної обсерваторії та
заклади що потребують доступу до
європейських цифрових інфраструктур в
І що ж
у європейська інтеграція є одним з
проявів тенденції сучасного історичного
розвитку посилення всебічної
взаємозалежності держав усіх сфер
діяльності при русі в сфері науки та
освіти в Європейський вибір України
зумовлює необхідність формування
освітньої і Наукової стратегії
європейської інтеграції за підтримки
Міністерства освіти і науки України за
ініціативи комісії та жаб у проекті я
створив технічну та інформаційну базу
для обміну науковою інформацією надав
цифровий сервіси уніфіковане до сервісом
Європи та опадають працюватиме для
підтримки спільноти науковців освітян
України які зацікавлені у Європейському
партнер стій та євроінтеграцію
і дякую
і це дуже дякую Дуже дякую пане Євгене
Отже Шановні колеги ми сьогодні почули
дуже багато цікавого і корисного
починаючи від тих змін які відбулися у
Союзі про нові зміни європейського
дослідницького простору пакт про
дослідницький простір Ми також почули
нові програми які стають доступними для
українських науковців і зараз перша
частина нашого заходу закінчується о
другій годині він знову розпочнеться
панельної дискусії про
впровадження в Україні
відкритої науки Да коли всім за увагу
гарного в
о.в.
а
отже
day in Ukraine продовжується і
продовжується він панельної дискусії яка
присвячена питанням впровадження
відкритої науки в Україні як вже
говорилося в першій частині
сьогоднішнього заходу Міністерство
освіти і науки України створила робочу
групу яка розробляє зараз план відкрить
національний план з відкритою науки
члени цієї робочої групи присутні зараз
з нами в залі а також нами в онлайні Я з
вашого дозволу їх представлю
це Олександр березко кандидат технічних
наук доцент національного університету
Львівської політехніки член правління
євро в Ми вітаємо пане Олександре
відкритого доступу проекту
член комісії Національної академії наук
України з інтеграції до Європейського
дослідницького простору та член
координаційної Ради з питань
інформатизації Президії Національної
академії наук України
Доброго дня
із нами в онлайні Ірина Дегтярьова член
консультативної ради Європейської ради
аспірантів і молодих вчених в
О Боже колеги я хотів би почати з такого
відносно простого для нас а можливо не
відносно складного в
А хто готовий сказати декілька слів з
а насправді відкрита наука не є чимось
драматичними
А якщо розбиратися відкрито наука це
просто наука яка здійснюється правильний
спосіб так
я думаю що для тих людей які були
змінювати закритою наукою не треба
очікувати якихось
науковців так драматичних змін
драматичних
еее нових підходів до власного того чим
вона займається це ж це відкриття самого
наукового процесу на всіх його етапах
застосовувати і
вона має дуже багато переваг для
науковців для наукових організацій про
це ще поговоримо сьогодні о
о пане Сергію пани і Пані Ірина і
А
я мабуть включився Так
дякую колеги за таке гарне запитання для
мене відкрита наук Олександр сказав що
це не нова парадигма але дивлячись на
політику Європейського Союзу і для мене
особисто є відкрита наука це якраз нова
парадигма нова філософія організації та
здійснення наукової діяльності як пані
Ірина підкреслила на всіх етапах
розвитку і дуже важливо підкреслити такі
риси як на мене відкрито і науки користі
для суспільства для економіки для
політики для світу для глобальних
викликів це відкритість це Довіра це
доброчесність це цінність кожного
наукову цінність наукової колаборації
командної роботи цінність внеску кожного
виду наукової діяльності та
інклюзивність всіх його вимірах
цінність відкритої науки А
загалом дякую дякую Ірино
я хочу сказати
згадуючи історію
еее роботи над угодою
щодо долучення України до рамкової
програми горизонт Європа
то окрема стаття була присвячено тим
питанням що українські організації і
країна в цілому повинна виконати ті ж
самі умови що стосуються питань
відкритої науки що стосуються політики
відкритої науки що і інші країни які
приєднуються до програми горизонт Європа
причому ці умови на момент підписання
угоди не були чітко і прямо визначені з
якої Скажімо так філософської причини
Тому що ці умови протягом семи 10 років
можуть бути змінені тобто в і питання
відкритої науки питання
Яким чином технічно будуть
реалізовуватись ті чи інші речі скажімо
відкритість даних обробка даних обмін
даними
обмін інформацією створення тих чи інших
консорціумів мереж відкрийте і скажімо
через два роки можливо з'являться нові
вимоги які треба буде Україні так само
як і умовні Польщі чи умовні Угорщині
виконувати
підтримали
політичну мову в рамках цієї угоди
приєднання до тих активностей що будуть
пов'язані з питаннями Open Science Я
знаю що з нами присутня Ірина брала
участь в ряді проектів по створені по
створенню національних планів відкритої
науки навіть країн Європейського Союзу
можете декілька слів розповісти про це в
і
це насправді
вимог Європейського Союзу і
напевно не залишилося європейської
країни де б ці національні плани або би
вже не були ухвалені або були насправді
останньому етапі розробки і можливо
варто згадати також що кілька тижнів
тому Генеральна асамблея Юнеско 190
країн світу проголосували за новий її
міжнародний
інструмент відкритої науки політичний 1
і зараз ми перебуваємо на такому етапі
коли вже існує політична воля і
політичне рішення що відкрита наука це
та наука яка яка буде наукою майбутнього
і йдеться власне про заходи як наприклад
наш національний план з відкритою науки
Дякую кожен з учасників
був і
у воду або розробки своїх проектів або
долучення до якихось європейських
організацій які стверджували розробляли
формували принципи відкритої
Олександра II
а потім у 2019 році
запустив програму так званих амбасадорів
послів відкрити різних країнах і в
Україні і Ну ми намагаємося і
намагаємося
культур тому що для багатьох стає
очевидним що вузьким місцем провадження
змін
[музика]
технології технології важливі потрібне
фінансування поки не буде культури
певної так нічого не вийде і тому саме
лапках це гамерська така діяльність Вона
надзвичайно важлива і я думаю що в
лапках Амбасадор відкритою науки
сьогодні є всі Ми так всі члени робочої
групи багато вчених Україні які
підтримують цей рух
згадайте будь ласка десь декілька років
тому Міністерство підтримував вас в
проведенні дослідження про те яким чином
українські вчені в і взагалі що
українські вчені знають про відкрито
Дякую
щоб побачити динаміку
рівня обізнаності
серед українських вчених проте певні
практики і що важливо є позитивна
динаміка Тобто Це очевидно проте також
очевидно що динаміка це біль швидка
більш динамічно серед вчених досвідчених
саме тому молоді вчені потребують
особливої уваги і я скажу що буквально
мабуть наступного тижня буде
опублікований препринт досліджень які ми
робили на рівні Європи який підтверджує
ці дані тобто дуже чітко молоді вчені
потребують додаткових у ринків і
додаткового додаткових ініціатив Дякую
будь ласка
працював не тільки в Україні а й в інших
країнах тому числі країнах Європейського
Союзу як вони взагалі цих країнах
ставляться до відкритої і можливо якісь
свої такі акценти ви зможете поставити
як
приклади впровадження тих чи інших
принципів відкритої науки в
університетах або наукових установах
у Дякую за запитання пане Григорію я
спершу хочу продовжити думку яку
розпочав Олександр березко щодо участі
молодих науковців зокрема
дуже цікаво що на Європейському рівні на
рівні ЄС розроблення впровадження
політики на загальноєвропейському рівні
одними з найактивніших учасників
амбасадорів є саме молоді науковці які
репрезентували свого часу євро до і
останні кілька президентів це зокрема
президенти за 5 років вони після
завершення своєї каденції вони
продовжили свою кар'єру саме реалізації
впровадження відкритої науки
нещодавно був визнаний одним з
найактивніших амбасадорів адвокатів
науки на
Європейського Союзу це дуже важливо А що
для молодих учених
відкрита наука є дійсно важливо але тут
дуже багато проблеми бар'єрів і одним з
таких бар'єрів крім зміни ментальності
дослідницької культури про яку вже
це є відсутність
цінності
відкритої науки на всіх етапах розвитку
наукової кар'єри зокрема на рівні
захисту дисертації підготовки дисертації
до захисту та присудження наукового
ступеня доктора філософії і якраз Якщо
говорити про інституційні практики на
які може бути спрямована активність тому
числі Сьогодні мені здається що краси
момент рівень докторської підготовки щоб
тренувати розвивати відповідні
компетенції і навички підвищувати рівень
обізнаності знання не тільки в плані
інструментального
у Але і в плані
цінності наприклад громадянської науки
яким чином залучати до участі громадян
різних категорій тому числі наприклад
середніх шкіл ми до речі сьогодні еее
підключилися я бачила дуже багато
представників середніх шкіл дитячих
садочків на наших
Для мене це дуже позитивний приклад
Якраз це сигнал що потрібно зближувати і
напрямок Якщо говорити про досвід країн
ЄС то звичайно все починалося кілька
років тому з відкритого доступу з більш
інструментального інфраструктурного
підходу тобто те що ми на Ми на цьому
напій Україна Ще наразі знаходиться на
етапі впровадження відкритого доступу
але мабуть
наш шанс ми можемо використати багато
практик добрих практик але також і і
невдалих можливо моментів які постали
перед європейськими країнами наприклад
асоціація університетів опублікувала
дослідження яким чином європейські
університети
там берегти опитуванні брало участь
також два українських університети
невідомо які б опитування відповідно
анонімне і я хотіла б тут навести три
ключів бар'єри в ключі від провадження
відкрито і науки в університетах за
результатами цього дослідження Якщо
говорити про
бар'єри це брак стимулів в тому числі на
етапі розвитку наукової кар'єри і
присудження наукового ступеня
прийняття на роботу просування
приступлення також наукового звання і
так далі другий момент законодавчі
перепони проблеми які виникають
національному законодавстві в
суперечностях в різних нормативних актах
re3 ці питання дуже серйозно це питання
фінансування Але якщо говорити про
драйвери
три основні які є домінують усіх
університетах це національній політики
це вимоги тих агентів які фінансують
наукові дослідження і це політика і
стимули Європейського Союзу відповідно
ці два перших драйвери можливо нам варто
в Україні саме На цьому сконцентруватися
саме на тому щоб відкрита наука була
пріоритетом національної політики не
лише в сфері досліджень але
загальнонаціональних пріоритетів також
цифрової економіки цифри зації
діджиталізації і нова інновації та далі
і вимоги агенцій які фінансують наукове
дослідження це Міністерство національний
фонд наукових досліджень Національна
академія наук і так далі це дуже важливі
мені здається для нас уроки і на цьому
Ми має А зараз сконцентруватися Дякую
ми знаємо що в Європейському Союзі і в
цілому в Європейському просторі
головним Я так думаю інструментом
відкритої науки реалізації принципів
наразі є європейська хмара
відкритою
Я би хотів вам задати питання щоб ви
сказали декілька слів цілому про йоск
про Європі
Cloud
і
можливо які
кроки вже зробила Україна в плані
приєднання до
Дякую
термін європейське хмара відкритої науки
це основне направлення робіт в Європі
Слід зазначити що хмари тут називають
технологію яка використовується для
збірник я коментував руки даних для
проведення досліджень
концепції
науки охоплюють всю лінійку технологічну
і
все що необхідно для проведення
досліджень загалом
на чотирьох важливих напрямках даних
навички сервіси та інфраструктура яка
використовується можна сказати що
хмара відкрийте науки це віртуальне
середовище
як відкритими сервісами для зберігання
управління аналізу та повторного
розповсюдження даних досліджень
незалежно від кордонів та наукових
напрямків дійсно
наразі має органи управління
асоціації і має
оперативне керування це у групи які
зосереджені на розробці стандартів і
процедур які використовуються в
провайдерами і користувачами
європейська хмара відкрити науки
створювалась не на пустому місці це
об'єднання існуючих й інфраструктуру і
дослідних інфраструктур які на той час
вже існували і які використовуються що ж
стосується України наразі Україна є
членом асоціації його і
це
цього року і
наші дослідна інфраструктури наше
інфраструктура є частиною європейських
хмари відкрити науки і використовуються
як для
локальних досліджень науковців академії
науки Міністерства освіти так і
європейцями в рамках спільних наукових
проектів
у Дякую пане Сергію колеги щось хочете
додали прийом може
сказав що
це технології також політики і навички і
член робочої групи
з підготовки та Стюартів людей які
працюють з науковими даними допомагають
науковцям працювати з науковими даними Я
думаю що це тема дати Стюартів для
України дуже актуальна зараз тому що це
той напрямок
розвивається
європейський науковий простір і ми
повинні не відставати Ми повинні дати
можливість нашим науковцям отримувати
таку саму підготовкою таких такі самі
сервіси і я думаю що нас вже є непогана
база на основі якої ми могли би це все
розвивати і так само і
навчаючись найкращими практиками які є в
інших країнах і
робочої групи напрацювати програму
підготовки стюардів і забезпечити
професіоналізації дата стюардів
сподіваюся що ми зможемо долучитися в
рамках виконання нашого національного
плану тут цієї діяльності
Олександра Скажіть будь ласка з вашого
досвіду роботи в одному з найкращих
українських університетів Тим паче в
технічному університеті чи
готові молоді вчені і досвідчені вчені
вашого університету зараз з працювати
приблизно за тими ж самими
правилами технічними умовами збереження
даних обміном даними
готовий середньому зараз український
науковець в
А до того щоб працювати з даними на
належному рівні
який від нас як від Країни еее скажімо в
проектах
Європи
Дякую запитання
скажемо так ідеологічно так наші
науковці Ну вони цілком нерівні чи є
вони Я ще ні ні Чи потребують вони
тренінгів чи потребують вони нових знань
так чи потребують вони інфраструктур так
тобто я свого досвіду скажу що буквально
вчора вносив правки вже якийсь там
знають 3 4 5 у велику статтю де є дані і
частини цього Дослідження які будуть
опубліковані відкритому доступі і Якби я
знав все те що я знаю зараз півтора роки
тому своїх цей процес був би значно
більш плавним
наші вчені А ну я не зустрічав жодного
разу
якихось супер
ідеологічних Скажем так заперечень
стосовно цієї відкритості тому що
особливо стосується технічних
спеціальностей для яких
взагалі Web World wide Web Internet і
відкриті системи стали чимось вже таким
самим звичайним як не знаю як Просто
чистити зуби наприклад Так але щоб
надати цьому
структурного підходу
щоб надати цьому підходу системного а
власне часто система вирішує так що буде
той чи інший науковець ефективний що
буде той чи інший проект чи той чи інший
проект буде ефективно потрібні ці речі
Ірина Кучма недарма щойно згадали про
стюардів даних їх можна називати
по-різному так їх можна назвати
провідниками стюарда ми може винайти
якийсь українське слово так щоб не
запозичати ні у але й функція супроводу
наукових даних правильно різними роботу
вона повинна бути забезпечена Також
потрібно думати про
і даних тому що це є надзвичайно важлива
складова інфраструктурна складова яка
напряму стосується ОСК А я місяць тому
можливо трохи менше був дуже цікаві
конференцію фрази ікра з там говорилося
питання відкрити і науки та даних і
роботи з даними і власне думка що зараз
навіть не настільки важливі відкриті
дані як важливі феях дані які наші
робочій групі ми домовимося називати
оптимізовано
чому це важливо тому що
обсяги даних який зараз генеруються
наукою індустрією державними структурами
так вони давно перевищили можливості
людини для змістовного їх опрацювання а
відповідно й
для збереження даних правильному форматі
опис даних правильним чином який дає
змогу робота машинам у працювати ці дані
це є одна з основних ідей того Куди
зараз рухається європейська Наукова
система
казали про
можете можливо людям які не розуміють
повного змісту Що таке вердані пояснити
що тут повному сенсі розумілося Я дуже
сподіваюся на духовність колеги Так але
якщо дуже просто ну файболекс
тобто якщо дуже просто а а й
дослідницькі дані наукові дані завгодно
які
форматі
ці дані повинні бути описані
таким чином що їх можна знайти так тобто
вони мають в
у ідентифікатор
тобто вони опубліковані під такої
ліцензії яка дає змогу їх з ними
працювати
даних сумісний технологічно сумісних з
іншими системами І скажемо так типами
даних і раю забула це означає що дані
здатні до повторного використання це
супер важливо тому що в науковому світі
сьогодні надто багато ресурси
витрачаються на винайдення велосипедами
постійного винаходом знову й знову
когось із квадратними колесами коло
трикутник але вже є нормальний велосипед
з круглими навіщо винаходити зараз я би
хотів щоб теж колеги прокоментували Тому
що тут є Ну не знаю що має великий
досвід власним
Мабуть що можна давати слово може такі
практичні приклади зараз еее коли
науковці подивись наукові статті
сьогодні журнали зазвичай міжнародні
журнали запитують де можна подивитися на
дані які використовувались для написання
цієї статті і бажано щоби рецензенти
цієї статті змогли мати доступ до цих
даних і справді подивитися що результати
статті Невигадані вони
основою
стаття написана на основі справжнього
Дослідження які
належним чином і якщо нас не буде
механізмів підтримки науковців щодо
належного менеджменту даних то Нажаль
науковці просто втратять можливість
публікуватися в наукових журналах тому
що їхні статті навіть не будуть
ухвалювати щодо
братися до розгляду редакціями журналів
Дякую пана Сергія скажіть будьласка Як
справи з цими питаннями Національної
академії наук України чи готові
українські вчені які працюють
в академіях вночі вони вже можливо
зберігають дані обмінюються даними
повторно використовують Дякую
повторного використання даних мають бути
доступний за посиланням даної мають
захищений як технічними засобами так і
юридично захищені в мати авторські права
і любові дослідник має до Повинен мати
можливість перевірити ці даних
використовують своїх дослідженнях але
тут є
певні проблеми перше з них Всі ці дані
повинні бути розміщений репозиторій
репозиторії повинні мати певний стандарт
[музика]
відкрити для
користування і а мають пройти
сертифікацію
наразі в Академії Наук
в Україні серед
репозиториев даних немає Є певні
роботи цьому є певний приклади дата
версия
загальна
теорія даних який відповідає усім
європейським вимогам хмари відкрити
науки наразі немає
це
питання мабуть
фінансове питання
потрібно мати певної обладнання це дуже
коштовне обладнання
повинне мати бути спеціалісти які
супроводжують даний репозитарій
тому тут безліч проблем і нас Ти знаєш
як Міністерство освіти і науки України
та Національна академія наук України
будуть і проблеми еее вирішувати вони не
є нездоланною це
зрозумілий процес якщо треба щоб і наша
з вами країна пройшла найближчим часом
тобто якщо ми змогли зробити за декілька
років національний репозитарій
академічних текстів які вже сьогодні
містить сотні тисяч наукових праць які
доступні онлайн 24 години на добу то я
думаю що можна і
зробити приблизно теж саме тільки цей
продукт буде використовуватись для
збереження та обробки наукових даних Тим
паче Що як ви розумієте добре з цифрами
працювати набагато простіше ніж текстами
тут всі проходили цей так і всі країни
всі мають певний доступ в
ми можемо скористатися цим доступом
організаційними питаннями
реалізувати репозиторію Нема проблем
Дякую пропоную трошки змістити акцент на
іншу сферу відкрийте або на інший
принцип
і перейти до питання відкритого
рецензування Я знаю що пана Олександра
заснував
ідею відкритого рецензування в своєму
університеті має досить цікавий проект
можете розказати декілька слів про дякую
З того що в Львівській політехніці ми
запустили такий пілотний проект який
називався
на якому ми намагалися відкрити
рецензування для наукових конференцій
зараз фактично
цей проект він виріс так і отримав
фінансування програми еразмус плюс і
таке Львівська політехніка і
координатором проекту оптіма Open
Пакистан в
академії
працює
про це розповісти бутіки слів чому
власне відкриття рецензування чому це
важливо і чому зараз на відкрити
рецензування велику ставку робить власне
Європейська комісія
якщо дуже коротко ну мабуть нема
науковця який би не Був знайомий з
процесом рецензування так скласти Таким
чином склалося історично що саме
рецензування тобто оцінювання грунтовний
аналіз і оцінювання
доробку вчених іншими вченими вважається
не таким Скажем так методом забезпечення
якості загальноприйнятим як показують
останні публікації від неї чертами до
кого завгодно все більше Більше питань
до цього процесу виникає через те що він
відбув в непрозорий спосіб відбувається
закриті спосіб як правило
стандартом рецензування так зване
подвійне сліпе рецензування коли ні
автор не знають один одного і
не публікуються відкритому доступі
відкрити рецензування це знову ж таки не
є щось дуже фіксована кілька наука сама
по собі Так є багато ознак відкритого
рецензування і
це теж такий концепт гнучкий проте
основна ідея Це відкрити процес тако
цієї комунікації і спрямувати його на те
щоби відхилити або прийняти статтю так а
для того щоб зробити участю кращою і
дотягнути до того моменту так щоб її
опублікувати і в такому випадку науковий
а результат вигляді статті вже не є
чимось дуже фіксованим мама й тато інший
життєвий цикл який дає змогу в процесі
комунікації між редактором автором
рецензента ми і науковою спільнотою
наприклад через коментування забезпечити
оцей такий шліфування Та коли ми
отримали камінчик вже гладеньких точно
не гарний кінці еее
А зараз на відкрити рецензування
величезну ставкою вже казав робить
Європейська комісія і тут формі
було запущено навесні цього року власне
відкрити рецензування є стандартним
способом ліцензування основний в я
склався ще розкажем так від євро доку
експертної групи яка працює над цим
проектом консультує його основне з
основних ідей є наступна якщо ми
відкриваємо і показуємо процесу прозорий
спосіб тоді немає підстав йому не вірити
і таким чином є великі шанси збільшити я
підвищити якість рецензій
уникнути скажемо так
дискримінації
уникнути якихось навіть негативних
моментів тому що рецензування це завжди
суб'єктивна думка вченого
А це завжди так щоб мене казали так вона
може бути більш суб'єктивним менше
об'єктивна Але якщо це робити відкрити
спосіб це працює і платформи такі якесь
тисячу наприклад Так платформи з цією
самою технологією wellcome trust
ірландської наукової організації та
багатьох інших
Білла і мелінди Гейтс фундації біла і
мелінди Гейтс і багато інших показують
ефективність цього
є ще один дуже важливим для мене
впровадження ліцензування в Україні є
одним з ключових це є аспект молодих
вчених тому що спільнота яка спільно
спільнота яка оточує ці статті дає
хороші коментарі фактично виступає
колективним ментором для молодих вчених
відкриває цей процес саме на самий
фокусується в проекті оптиму Дякую
Скільки українських університетів бере
участь у взагалі можемо Ви знаєте
скільки українських університетів
наприклад до вашої платформи вже
приєднувалися бо відчула цей досвід в
розробці запуск в липні цього 22 року
чотири Львівська політехніка Сумський
Державний Донецький національний Вінниці
Луцький національний технічний
університет Проте ми дуже сподіваємося
що власне на платформі будуть
представлені ну всі українські
університети і дуже багато зарубіжних
адже лише міжнародна оцінка наукових
здобутків може мати справжню цінність На
мою думку Дякую А хто Готовий Ще
долучитись до дискусії по відкритому
рецензування Можливо
трошки сьогодні вже згадували горизонт
Європа нова рамкова програма
Європейського Союзу Наукова і відкрита
наука цій програмі є є
за
механізмом забезпечення якості наукового
проекту
науковці які подають проекти повинні вже
на етапі проекту заявки написати як вони
практикують відкрито науку як вони
впроваджують супроводжуватимуть відкрити
науку в рамках запланованого проекту і
обов'язкові практики відкритої науки як
відкрити доступ до опублікованих
статей
менеджмент даних за принципами
й рекомендовані практики і от власне
відкрити рецензування це рекомендована
практика відкритої науки і
і практикуючи це Можна забезпечити собі
більше балів на етапі оцінювання заявки
і ще можливо варто наголосити що в
А це можливість також поліпшити якість
статті тому що
справді конструктивна якщо пропонується
якісь
доповнення до статті то тоді
публікується нова версія
доопрацьована версія цієї статті за на
основі зауваження рецензентів і були
цікаві прецеденти коли
президенти фактично стали співавторами
статей тому що їхній внесок був
настільки Вагома що вони зустрічалися як
співавтори і потім в
а починалося низка спільних проектів
Тобто Це непоганий механізм справді
розширити коло своїх нових партнерів
більше шансів отримати фінансування на
Наукові дослідження Дякую
ви хочете в
у дякую дякую дуже Я хочу підкреслити що
колеги вже зазначили Що відкрити
рецензування На мою думку
повертає
рецензій наукові рецензії природньо
природну характеристику тобто ідея
діалогу ідея наукового діалогу про певну
наукову проблематику і говорячи про
відкрити рецензування Мені здається ми
не слушно зупиняємося лише на
публікаціях оскільки відкрити
рецензування має стосуватися і
стосуються в концепції Європейської
комісії також наприклад рецензії
наукових проектів які подаються до
фінансування це вже більш проблематично
звичайно бо вимагає формування певної
низки етичних принципів принципів
уникнення конфлікту інтересів
які мають дотриманні яких має
дотримуватися також рецензенти
відповідно і проблематика з лютого
рецензування і необхідність впровадження
певних нормативних регуляції стосується
не лише виключно
індивідуальних науковців але також
наприклад видавців і організації які
фінансують наукові дослідження і ще один
важливий момент це
ідея
оскільки
розуміння наукових результатів наукових
продуктів досягнень лише в розрізі
наукових публікацій А ще бажано
це якраз не відповідає ідеї відкритої
науки оскільки яка посилює розширення і
оцінювання всіх видів наукових досягнень
відповідно
оцінення наукової рецензії як наукового
досягнення також має бути визнана рівні
оцінювання якості наукової діяльності
для наукових працівників і
не варто також згадати практику
відкритого рецензування якщо можна його
Звичайно так назвати практику опанування
дисертацій коли публікуються відкритому
доступі відгуки офіційних опонентів це
теж є свого роду
рецензія на певну наукову роботу яка
сформована за певним стандартам і так
далі відкритому рецензуванні звичайно
дуже важлива важлива Роль відводиться
практикам етики і дослідницької
доброчесності зокрема доброчесності в
розрізі
видавців які відповідають принципам
організації яка займається саме
публікацією
нашим українським видавцям та
українським закладами освіти науковими
установами Варто звернути на це увагу
власне як в ролі видавців не лише як
операторів на у своїй діяльності і це ж
саме стосується звичайно питання даних і
взагалі еее відкрита наука вона створила
абсолютно відкрила абсолютно Нове Поле
фахівці на формування яких Сьогодні
мають бути також спрямовані зусилля в
українських університетах зокрема також
фахівців і дати і так далі І взагалі
ідея
Вона має бути впровадженням українських
університетах можливо у закладах вищої
освіти який сьогодні створюються які
мають бути сфокусовані на саме ідея
президентського університету
дуже хочеться щоб там Все таке знайшла
відображення ідей а також підготовки
дати Стюарт Мені здається це дуже гарне
місце для реалізації такої ідеї Дякую
хотів би трошки перевести тему на Інше
питання на інший розріз які стосуються
Відкрий і науки це
поговорити про
удосконалення системи оцінювання якості
наукової діяльності тобто чи відкрита
наука може допомогти
може зробити
цей процес
зрозумілішим відкриті шим простішим для
наших українських вчених і українських
наукових установ Я декілька слів скажу
оскільки був долучених до тих чи інших
процесів
міністерстві і ми бачимо що проблема
збору даних збору інформації про себе
про свій науковий колектив про кафедру
чи відділ
ця проблема існує тобто український
вчений в
а від часу вимушений збирати ту чи іншу
звітну інформацію про те Які в нього є
здобутки результати таке інше для того
щоб а або податись на якісь науковий
проект заповнити якісь форми
еее зробити звіт діяльності своєї
установи пройти державну атестацію
чи може
робота яка пов'язана з розробкою
національного плану з відкрити на вашу
думку допомогти звичайному українському
вченому в
а
я думаю що це абсолютно ключова тема і
без зміни системи оцінювання наукової
діяльності впровадження відкритої науки
і інших супутніх реформ є неможливим Це
дуже добре розуміють в Європі і зараз
assessments тобто оцінювання наукової
діяльності є одною з ключових тем
абсолютно а це точиться багато дебатів
але що знаково що дебати точиться дуже
багато різних думок залучає
стейкхолдерів є багато консультації але
не всім зрозумілі речі певних систем
потребує реформ у чому швидкість і друге
а
а від нова система оцінювання повинна
базуватися на принципах відкритий і
враховувати ці нові підходи
еее На жаль в Україні Сучасна система
оцінювання і загалом скажу в Україні і
ті Системи які є в Вищу закладах вищої
освіти На мою думку вкрай недосконалим
тому що те що ми
стимулює теми по суті отримую і нерідко
бачимо що стимулюються
насамперед кількісні показники
результаті ми отримуємо інколи штучну
появу високих значення кількісних
показників і менше уваги приділяється
показникам якісними показниками а
якісному змісту Так це проблема Ну щоб
бути зовсім відвертим це лише України
проблема це проблема всього світу так
напевно А так само
відкритої
розробки національного плану його потім
впровадженні звичайно Так вони
нерозривно пов'язані з реформою
оцінювання наукової діяльності хочу
кілька пунктів зараз просто зазначити 1
це звичайно
відхід від кількісних показників не
повністю але сприймання їх як
допоміжного елементу та впровадження
більш якісного оцінювання
сподіваєшся розповість про наративні
сім'ї так інші фактичні інструмент еее
а визнання широкого спектру наукових
результатів тобто не лише публікації
статей і не лише наприклад
і ціла низка інших активностей інших
результатів зокрема збір даних про що
сьогодні вже багато йшлося те саме
відкрити рецензування Дякуємо таке про
це згадала обов'язково відкриті рецензії
так повинні стати визнаним що важливо
науковим результатом здобутком який
потрапляє в систему оцінювання і багато
інших так і тут в
і багато організації на заході так
вирішується питання наприклад підписання
певних декларація така декларація
сан-франциско
маніфест підписання догори це класне
крок декларативний Але якщо це не
підкріплено змінами реальними так такий
крок має дуже мало практичне
застосування тобто якщо підсумувати
ми не можемо
без зміни системи оцінювання і система
землю системи оцінювання без орієнтації
на ціною практики теж не має Великого
сенсу це як Інь і Янь так вони йдуть по
тому як завжди в комплексі Дякую хочете
тема вже згадали пане Григорію що не
повинні науковці щомісяця чи ще два
місяці заповнювати ті самі таблиці або
трошки
у таблиці оскільки йдеться про
науку цифровому середовищі
має бути
вже повинні бути доступні
[музика]
мають підтримувати свою публічні
профайли
еее актуальному стані і наукові
організації чи наукові фонди просто
заходять на профайл цього вченого
інформацію про публікації
ще цікаві зміни відбуваються в
Нідерландах зараз де університети
сказали що що досить що-небудь і
дивитися на
фактори журналів коли вони оцінюють
науковців тому що
немає ніякого зв'язку між фактором
журналу і якістю індивідуальної статті
діяльністю окремого науковця А що вони
будуть робити вони будуть просити
науковців розповісти про свої досягнення
і ці досягнення можуть бути або вигляді
наративних сім'ї окрім
списку публікацій
є ще пояснення які власне вплив ця
публікація здійснила також контексті
горизонт Європа можна згадати що заявка
проектна включає формулу де надається
інформація про і там потрібно зазначити
ті статті які мають бути відкритому
доступі або ті дані які є доступними які
мали найбільший вплив які науковець
вважає
найважливішими і саме на це буде
дивитися у на
найважливіші наукові досягнення а не
якісь
і довгий список публікацій які
важливо
Європейська комісія
університету
європейське наукові фонди
започатковують так звану коаліцією тих
хто справді є в лютому вона буде
заснована де
власне й
а її заснування стане результатом
багаторічних дискусій про те що що варто
змінювати
наукову оцінку і будемо сподіватися що
ці зміни також будуть підтримані
українськими університетами і науковцями
і
це справді зекономити час
полегшить
інтеграція науковців
[музика]
Або
можливо знають про те що Минулого року
Міністерство освіти і науки України це
[музика]
в оренду був підписаний і наразі та
команда яка розвиває створює національну
наукову інформаційну систему нашу Вона
має доступ до таких даних і ці дані
відповідно вже є і будуть оновлюватись
цій системі
і безпосередньо така інтеграція
дозволить пришвидшити оновлення даних
А про як окремих українських вчених так
і в цілому по організації до яких вони
афілійовані
можливо пану Сергію задати питання А як
взагалі ситуація
в національній Академії Наук з точки
зору
процесу система оцінювання діяльності чи
приходиться вам та вашим колегам довго
чи недовго збирати дані про результати
своєї діяльності Чи Ви допомагаєте
цифрова цей процес Дякую
Національної академії наук є
власна методика оцінювання
наукових установ і підрозділів наукових
установ в є певна процедура
доступна на сайті є певний набір
документів
таблиць які
і заповнюють
підрозділи
установи ідея оцінювання оцінювання на
відміну від
монад експертне
не тільки ті документи які формуються
підготовки до оцінювання експертна
комісія виїжджає
установу і проводять співбесіди як
співробітниками відділив так і загалом
співробітниками дирекції інституту
що касається
збору документів да це певна процедура
хоча існує система
яка
автоматизує цей процес на доступне і
основі з даних таблиці і форми заповнює
вчений секретар в рамках системи
Слід зазначити наш інститут проходив
оцінювання
пару місяців тому і це дуже велике купа
таблиці документів даних які стосуються
як фінансової діяльності як окремого
відділу так інституту участі в грантах
публікації
даних які потрібно ви як людина зайти
Скажімо так сфери ви бачите
світ в кінці тунеля цьому питанні в
плані того що ви бачите якийсь алгоритм
який допоможе це все ж таки
еее ці дані всі збирати автоматично без
втручання людини інтегрально чи це
перш за все Я згоден що потрібно а
змінювати систему оцінювання вона
повинна удосконалюватися
критерії вже казали
всі ці дані які
збирались підрозділом вони повинен бути
доступний як зовнішніх репозитарій якщо
стосується публікації що стосуються
фінансової діяльності
репозиторії загальна система Академії
Наук або Міністерства і
я вважаю що цей процес
автоматизувати
як по збору первинних даних так по їх і
аналізу
критеріїв формування Дякую пану Сергію А
я хотів би
трошки перенести нашу дискусію нас так
багато час залишилась ще на Інше питання
що стосуються і науки
це це питання громадянської
якщо в
не складно було сказати що будь-яка
людина будь-яка дитина може мати доступ
до просто величезного обсягу різного
роду наукової інформації то зараз
будь-яка людина маючи смартфон планшет
або інший технічний пристрій
може
побачити в
у массу даних які вона може сприйняти
обробити ви сказати якусь свою думку Тим
паче в епоху такого глобального
карантину і де кожна людина може
побачити як це все відбувається в світі
так само спостерігаючи за даними або з
результатами обробки якихось даних тощо
тобто
в суспільстві світі з'являється
купа
вчених
Що ви можете сказати про цей ефект
можливо 21 сторіччя і
ваші Думки щодо радянських
якщо можна почну
еее мені зразу спадає до думку кілька
років тому
була гра Pokemon Go так багато хто чув
коли та з актуальних Покемонів істот і
таким чином
що ті люди які зробили цю гру отримали
безпрецедентний
доступ до певних даних багато було
дискусії про маски які давали змогу
зістарити скажемо так людські зображення
фейсбуку Так що це теж великий
експеримент і тому подібне Так звичайно
сьогодні Кожен з нас Note
з вами звичайний кожного кишені за
своїми численними потужностями справді
вже стає дуже серйозно І справді можна
залучати громадськість в і знову дітей
так само тобто наймолодшого віку до
допомоги вченим до змістовної діяльності
Але скажу так що з того що мені відомо
Немає чіткого розуміння
як це робити І
багато вчених побоюються залученню
громадськості так тому що ніби еее Ну
тобто як ми можемо залучити
непрофесіоналів людей які не руйнуються
але ж дівчина каже щоб залучати цих
учасників так процесу на рівні
концептуалізації експеримент йдеться про
волонтерство насамперед так правило
тестом можливо за якісь інші бонуси так
залучення громадськості до таких от Якщо
хочете навіть технічних завдань які
можуть бути дуже цікавим але ще один
важливий момент відкритою науки і в
контексті саме
контакту і взаємодії з громадськістю На
мою думку це Пояснення результатів
наукових у широкому загалу тобто якщо
скажімо зараз вчений просто публікує
свою статтю На мою думку цього
недостатньо Ви повинні намагатись
перекладати цю статтю іншими мовами в
лапках так
званими ну тобто спрощено умовою для
непрофесіоналів можливо готувати ще одну
версію для
людей які приймають рішення для
політиків для
того щоби покращити якість
це теж дуже важливо відкритої науки і
громадянської
Дякую
додати давайте хвилинку не більше так
Ірина якщо
Дякую Дуже хочу продовжити цю думку для
мене особисто громадянська наука це
насамперед про формування наукового
світогляду громадян і яка також
стосується і популяризації науки на
результатів на поводі У проекті зазначив
Олександр здається що в Україні з одного
боку є досить гарна гарне підґрунтя для
цього є Мала академія наук досить
розгалужена система національних центрів
екологічних є система наукових ліцеїв це
велике досягнення що наукові ліцеї боги
прописані в законі Про наукову і
науково-технічну діяльність Мені
здається це дуже важливий елемент
який може стати елементом громадянської
науки але це з іншого боку накладає
також на законодавця на заклади вищої
освіти Національної академії наук такий
обов'язок наукової Просвіти тобто
підвищення обізнаності громадян і
зокрема цих людей цих осіб наукових
ліцей учнів і тд які цим займаються
дитячих садочків сьогодні долучилися до
наших в
а саме підвищення обізнаності також про
відкрито науку про якісного діяльності
наприклад про хижацький журнали так щоб
вони розуміли що таке етичні принципи що
таке дослідницька доброчесність А що
таке не доброчесність так що можливо
фальсифікація
плагіат
і
активісти мають популяризувати етичні
принципи але тут-таки містом до
попередньої теми щодо оцінювання якості
наукової діяльності на сьогоднішній день
чи оцінюється Чи враховуються участь
науковці наприклад у наукових пікніків у
якихось лекціях наукових ліцеях Чи
враховуються в оцінюванні якості
наукової діяльності
можливо враховуються але за залишковим
принципом і точно не є вирішальним і тут
мені здається це дуже важливий елемент у
цій А які ми маємо теж змінити в
українській
реальності але підґрунтя і
бібліотек
бібліотек як провайдерів і
а в Україні бібліотеки
започаткували репозитарії наукових
публікацій їх у нас понад
160 бібліотеки також
проводять тренінги допомагають
науковцям слідкувати за тим що нового в
в
в умовах наукових фондів як змінюються
вимоги наукових журналів еее і
бібліотекаря також можуть бути
даних про які ми згадували + підтримка
громадянської сказала що це фактично на
інноваційність підрозділи університетів
головні ідеологічні виконавців
Дуже дякую
Я сподіваюсь що та команда яка зараз
працює над розробкою національного плану
з відкритою науки над реалізацією
окремих ідеї які його стосуються
еее найближчий час можливо найближчі
місяці
еее нашому суспільству на громадське
обговорення видасть ти
з цього національного плану можливо ми
ще спробуємо почути якісь ідеї які якісь
пропозиції які до нього надійдуть і у
2022 році під час такої ж самої дискусії
через рік кінці кінці 22-го року ви вже
будемо говорити про те що цей пункт ця
це завдання в дорожній карті інтеграції
до Європейського дослідницького простору
нашою країною виконано 7 Дуже дякую
Дякуємо
Далі
будемо продовжувати
наша
еее наш
перейде до наступної теми що буде
стосуватися питань інновацій Ми багато
сьогодні говорили Про науку
згадували в у літак але хотілося б
окремо поспілкуватись на цю тему з
фахівцями які я зараз запрошую зайняти
місця в
А за нашою темою
і
питання будуть стосуватись відкритих
інновацій та розвитку
економіки що побудована на знаннях з
і ми будемо говорити про удосконалення
політики підтримки інновацій в Україні
ми будемо говорити про законодавчі
ініціативи які зараз
пропонується міністерством освіти і
науки України
тож разом з нами
зараз в А пан Ігор таранов виконуючий
обов'язки генерального директора
директорату науки та інновацій
Міністерство освіти і науки України і
керівника експертної групи з питань
розвитку інновацій
пані Оксана крукевич
експерт з питань розвитку інновацій
Міністерства освіти і науки України
інституту міжнародної політики
думаю що
еее
останні законодавчі ініціативи були в
сфері інновацій
Дякую пане Григорію звичайно проблема
розвитку інновацій в Україні не
залишається поза увагою Міністерства
освіти і науки України і Міністерство як
1 з ключових органів центральної
виконавчої влади що посідає певні
повноваження у сфері інноваційної
діяльності
розробляє ряд документів державної
політики що є надзвичайно потрібними і
важливими
насамперед я все ж таки повернувся до
2019 року і нагадаю усім нашим слухачам
сьогодні та учасникам про те що у липні
2019року Кабінету Міністрів України була
схвалена стратегія розвитку сфери
інноваційної діяльністю до 2030 року і
буквально два тижні тому уряд схвалив
план заходів по реалізації стратегії до
2023 року саме цим планом заходів
передбачається виконання ряду завдань
які сприятимуть пожвавлення інноваційної
діяльності а також прийняттю знову ж
таки нових документів державної політики
у сфері інноваційної діяльності і
одночасно хоче нагадати про те що 7
вересня цього року президент підписав
у номер 17 14 який спрямований на
активізацію діяльності та розвитку
наукових парків що також пожвавити
інноваційну діяльність у закладах вищої
освіти у наукових установах у всіх
суб'єктів господарської діяльності у
формі господарського товариства що мають
назву науковий парк тому що цим законом
передбачається ряд преференцій а саме
створення нового парку без погодження із
міністерством освіти і науки України
Тобто де регулювання процесу створення
парку надання умов щодо здачі в оренду
приміщень для функціонування наукову
парку на умовах Як для бюджетних установ
та ряд інших серед надзвичайно важливих
документів державної політики які
розробляються міністерством і вже
фактично проходять стадію фінальну
погодження із центральними органами
виконавчої влади це новий
фундаментальний закон про під у і
розвиток інноваційної діяльності
ще один із законопроектів спрямований на
підтримку інновації в Україні це
законопроект Про інноваційні парки
законопроект 55 29 який був схвалений
комітетом Верховної Ради з питань освіти
науки та інновацій у першому читанні
також спрямований на те щоб надати певну
фінансову автономію
державним університетом частині
комерціалізації їхніх розробок ідеться
про те що 30 таких коштів університети
будуть мати право зараховувати до
спеціального фонду А це матиме певний
вплив на забезпечення фінансової
автономії Ну і знову ж таке ще один
надзвичайно важливий законопроект який
потрібен Україні потрібен усім і
новатором це закон який би стосувався
покращення сфері трансферу технологій
Міністерства власне розробило
законопроект у і ми Очікуємо на те що
він знайде своє відображення у
прийнятому законі що також сприятиме
покращенню сфері трансферу технологій
Дякую з
у
20-і серед напрямків є напрямок для
середнього та малого бізнесу Тобто ми
уже готові приймати проекти від
представників середнього та малого
бізнесу це саме науково-технічні проекти
Обов'язковою умовою є співпраця з
науковими установами та закладами вищої
освіти Таким чином Міністерство
сподівається що цей конкурс дасть
можливість побудувати міцну співпрацю
між представниками бізнесу та наукової
спільноти щодо цифрових інструментів Ми
уже презентували платформу науки бізнес
зараз ви побачите також на екрані
коротке відео про те як вона вже працює
а в кінці відео буде лінк за яким можна
переходити і ознайомитися уже з наявним
функціоналом А в чому суть цієї
платформи тому що учасники можуть
зареєструватися і подати якщо ви
науковець свої проекти які ви вже
реалізували а свої результати наукової
діяльності у або написати сферу які ви
готові надавати експертиз наукову і
відповідно представників бізнесу зможуть
знайти те рішення яке їм цікавить і
конкретизувати вашу розробку а
представники бізнесу можуть
зареєструватися також подати відповідний
запит на співпрацю можуть також
запропонувати спільне виконання проектів
а також розмістити запити Про необхідні
їм рішення для розвитку свого бізнесу
тому я сподіваюсь що це інструмент буде
дуже корисним Уже можна зареєструватися
і буквально найближчим часом ми
оголосимо про запуск
офіційний на національному рівні цієї
платформи і ще досить цікаві інструменти
комунікаційні ми вже запровадили в цьому
році і провели sunsun бізнес
а також буквально Вчора ми провели
бізнес для моделей цих заходів на темпах
Ми збираємося і Новаторів науковців
представників бізнесу і навчаємо їх
протягом дводенного інтенсивно основам
як прописувати проекти які будуть цікаві
бізнесу як готувати Startup рішення які
будуть конкуренти здатні на міжнародній
арені зокрема А знання в сфері фінансів
в інвестиції юридично панелі
інтелектуальна власність Тобто всі ті
знання які потрібні для того щоб
підготувати дійсно до станції
конкурентоздатний продукт і вчора ми вже
мали дуже хороший результат і прослухали
11 чудових
було три переможці які підготували
дійсно дуже цікаві інноваційність
стартапи отримали унікальні подарунки
від наших партнерів ми залучаємо а
провідні компанії такі як ДТЕК також
юніт Сіті які надали унікальні призи
Тому ці заходи будуть продовжені у 22
році в Ми запрошуємо слідкувати за
нашими анонсами і нас чекає дуже багато
на відміну від
не працюєте Міністерство освіти і науки
України але я думаю що вам є що сказати
можливо зі сторони про питання розвитку
інновацій тільки тісну співпрацю з
міністерством освіти та науки у мене
іноді враження що я з вами працюю
формі форми співпраці дійсно є різниця
Насправді я я дуже мені дуже сподобалася
ідея про про співпрацю між наукою тобі
тому що саме моя тема чому чому мене
Міністерство запросили на цей захід це
говорити про смерть спеціалізації смак
спеціалізація це саме і початок бізнесу
і науки співпраця діалог Smart
спеціалізація це комунікація це
знаходження унікальних рис до регіону
кожне області в Україні які зможуть
побудувати
свої свій оцей ланцюг між наукою та
бізнесом і ми всі розуміємо що дуже
часто коли починає роботу процес
підприємницької відкриття в будь-якій
області в цьому році у нас дуже гарні
результати мають п'ять областей це
Київська Донецька Луганська
Тернопільська Львівська там ідуть
активно процес підприємницького
відкриття ми вчора презентували
результати на нашій конференції Я хочу
скористатися можливістю сказати про те
що можна її переглянути Я думаю буде
цікаво теж подивитися як працюють
регіони там були представники влади які
є красії розказували Саме ці пріоритети
які зараз потенційно вимальовується
областях України всіх робочих груп можна
доєднатися якщо є хтось хто на зараз чує
з інших областей які є а
й координатори в кожній області по
спеціалізації і науковці можуть
доєднатися тому що завдання Smart
спеціалізації це якраз і зрозуміти хто з
науковців в області є з унікальних
публікацій і досліджень і щоб ці
дослідження не просто посідали щоб вони
залишалися на папері або в колі
науковців і наукових конференцій вони
практично має застосовуватися бізнесом в
тому ж регіоні Таким чином піднімаючи
бізнес і
регіони на зовсім інший рівень розвитку
і оцей ця модель поєднання науки та
бізнесу через платформу це одна із дуже
гарних інструментів які якраз можна може
і використовувати бізнеси наука разом
крім того є ще платформа Smart
спеціалізації це платформа спільно
дослідницького центру який дуже активно
допомагає і тільки Україні іншим країнам
східного партнерства в провадженні і
розробки стратегії Smart спеціалізації
на початку розробки впровадження і якщо
просто пошук Google S3 платформ можна
відразу знайти і побачити там українські
регіони які зареєстровані поки там що
поки що там нема ще жодної стратегії
Smart спеціалізації українських регіонів
але 22 році у нас амбітна мета що
чернетки принаймні матимуть п'ять
українських областей це Київська
Донецька Луганська Тернопільська
Львівська крім того 22 році у нас
областей з якими будуть працювати
європейські експерти спільно
дослідницького центру це Львівська
Тернопільська Київська Хмельницька
Одеська івано-франківська і Вінницька
тому з тих областей якщо чують науковці
тут можна якраз доєднатися до роботи в
рамках процесу а відкриття
розказати про свої дослідження які є в
області у саме цих науковців і таким
чином
перетворювати перетворювати свої
дослідження в життя і допомагати бізнесу
Таким чином розвиватися можете сказати
що треба робити на слухає наприклад
зараз український науковець наприклад з
Тернопільщини Так де йому шукати
інформацію чи зараз вже вона є доступною
якщо ми говоримо області які
перерахувала 5 областей Тернопільська
Львівська Донецька Луганська і і
то нам сайті Обласної Державної
адміністрації мають бути обов'язково
інформацію про смерть спеціалізація це
один
одного джерела інші джерела
цес платформа S3 спільного
дослідницького центру там є контакти
координатора Smart спеціалізації по
області Я думаю що найкращий найшвидший
варіант цю платформу знайти знайти свою
області звернутися напряму саме до цього
координатора
[музика]
ми допомагаємо
зрушувати питання спеціалізації
дуже
цікаве і
розробки різноманітних документів що
стосуються підтримки та розвитку
спеціалізації насамперед потрібно
сказати Те що на вчорашній конференції Я
знову і підтвердив готовність усіх наших
наукових установ закладів вищої освіти
долучитися до розробки регіональних
стратегій Smart спеціалізації в частині
надання допомоги щодо визначення науково
будь-яка і спеціалізацію регіонів може
бути Smart адже ми говоримо про те що в
умовах певних обмежень фінансових
ресурсів потрібно використати всі
можливості для того щоби з найменшої
інвестиції можна було досягти найкращого
ефекту це перший напрямок такої
співпраці як ми можемо допомогти і при
цьому платформа про яку вже сьогодні
Оксана згадувала це теж є одне із джерел
інформації де можна почерпнути
інформацію про те хто потенційно може
долучитися більше того ми працюємо Надії
ще по інших напрямках зокрема ми знаємо
що спільна мінекономіки істот
міжнародної політики розробляють
методичні рекомендації щодо визначення
Smart спеціалізації цей документ власне
теж Міністерство наша опрацьовану ми
готуємо відповідні матеріали для
надсилання з інформацію щодо нашої
позиції стосовно розробки таких
документів державної політики і ще треба
відмітити що ми також приєдналися до
інших ініціатив ж стосується розробив
дорожніх карт теж частині які стосуються
засад Smart спеціалізації Дякую
я знаю що Україна
проявила ініціативу і заявила про участь
у пілотні програмі
Організації Об'єднаних Націй з розробки
дорожніх карт на основі
науки та інновацій дорожніх карт
досягнення цілей сталого розвитку
абсолютно правильно пане Григорію
що ви можете розказати про це на
сьогоднішній день дана ініціатива
перебуває в розробці Як ви знаєте із
нашого Міністерства до цього процесу
долучення експертна група з питань
моніторингу наукової та інноваційної
діяльності і вони працюють в цьому
напрямку тобто пропозиції які будуть
виношувати це вони обов'язково будуть
обговорюватися громадськістю для того
щоб ми все-таки могли імплементувати
цілі у його розвитку в Україні визначені
ООН робота триває Я сподіваюся що усі
речі які були відбувається на засіданнях
цих груп будуть оприлюднені і будуть
моніторити ся громадськістю думка
громадськості обов'язковому порядку буде
врахована
Дякую А розкажіть будьласка про
ініціативи які були
міністерстві щодо створення центру
трансферу технологій в Україні Дякую
пане Григорію за запитання якщо йдеться
про ініціативи щодо реалізації проекту
пілотного проекту створення мережі
центрів трансферу технологій та цей
проект уже реалізований він фактично
закінчується у 2021 році даний центр у
місті Києві один у південному регіоні це
у місті Одесі на базі Одеського
національного економічного університету
функціонує у місті Харкові на базі центр
трансферу технологій харківські
технології в у проект який був пілотним
і його основна мета була надати
методичну підтримку і новатором щодо
питань просування їх інновацій та
комерціалізації їх поза тим Хочу
наголосити що планом заходів по
реалізації стратегії розвитку сфері
інноваційної діяльності Ми також
передбачає можливість створення таких
центрів У подальшому кожному обласному
центрі України Тобто ми маємо на меті
розбудовувати дану мережу щоби у кожному
регіоні був такий центр так як сьогодні
підкреслювала що кожен регіон буде
розробляти свою стратегію Smart
металізації ми маємо намір створювати
такі центри скрізь іще додаткової таким
один із заходів які ми плануємо теж
реалізувати в рамках плану заходів по
реалізації стратегії розвитку сфери
інноваційної діяльності це створення
мережі страв школа інкубатор акселератор
це теж дуже цікава річ у багатьох
університетах на сьогодні у існують
центри підтримки трансфер технологій але
вони ще не об'єднані в мережу до якої ми
хочемо їх підключити і одна із
можливостей платформа наука і Бізнес яка
буде давати достатню інформацію для того
щоб центри могли й оперативно отримувати
Таким чином якщо Ми створимо дану мережу
по усій території України то Україна
буде об'єднана таке і мережею центрів
трансферу технологій що спростить
комунікацію між ними Але знову ж таки
хоче наголосити що для цього Нам
необхідно прийняти закон який би
врегулював питання трансфер технологій в
Україні адже наші ініціативи у цьому
законопроектів які стосуються насамперед
інструментів фінансової підтримки такі
як інноваційні ваучер такий підтримка
закордонного патентування такий
інструмент як субсидіювання створення
високотехнологічних спільних підприємств
із закладами освіти заслуговують на
підтримку наших парламентарів
у дякую пані Надія чи можна в контексті
інноваційних структур А якщо
трансфер технологій та мережу Startup
шкіру бізнес-інкубаторів а також ще
повідомлю що наразі міністерстві
готуються аналітика щодо наявної
інфраструктури вона вже на фінальній
стадії І що дуже важливо що вона буде
інтегрована на платформі на якої бізнес
у формі інтерактивної карти тому буде
дуже зручно зайти усім нашим
стейкхолдерами подивитись саме в якому
регіоні Яка й інноваційна інфраструктура
і тоді буде зрозуміло де потрібно
збільшувати акценти потрібно взяти
якийсь один із елементів інноваційної
інфраструктури і зможе дійсно побудувати
таку а мережу А яка дозволить
забезпечити от дійсно весь ланцюг
інноваційної діяльності від ідеї до
втілення рішення і вже до
комерціалізації його і впровадження на
підприємстві А я хочу щоб підтримати
ідею пане будь-які сказав за створення
інструментів для підтримки Smart
спеціалізації якщо ми говоримо за
взагалі за кількість стратегія
спеціалізації які мають бути в Україні
це 25
місто Київ і по суті жодної зараз немає
областей
і це означає що вони ще мають вступати в
цей процес активно залучатися і еее
звичайно рішення про
основне рішення основне офіційне рішення
приймається на рівні обласних державних
адміністрацій але ініціатива від
науковців відстав від різних інкубаторів
від від шкіл Тобто вона може виходити
саме звіт звідси тому що вони можуть
звернутися до влади сказати ми хочемо
нам цікавими готові цей процес
супроводжувати і сам у провадженні цього
процесу завжди є такий момент коли
владу треба трошки підштовхнути офіційне
рішення вони звичайно мають приймати на
рівні Обласної Державної адміністрації
офіційне рішення я маю на увазі це
розпорядження Обласної Державної
адміністрації про створення робочої
групи яка займається Smart спеціалізації
призначення координатора Smart
спеціалізації в області всі ці області
про які сьогодні згадували Вони мають і
мають це розпорядження і мають дорожню
карту процесу підприємницького відкриття
Дякую
створення нових і
у створити такі продукти які виведуть
нашу Україну в лідерство в окремих
можливо якихось галузях
Скажіть будь ласка
які що ми повинні зробити або яких цілей
Ми повинні досягнути
найближчим часом сфері інновацій для
того щоб для того щоб досягти якогось
конкретного результату наприклад посісти
якесь місце в якомусь рейтингу можливо А
для цього треба там якісь конкретні
кроки пройти багато про що говорили вже
от зараз можливо тут щось таке зазначити
більш конкретна для того щоб зрозуміти й
протягом трьох років або протягом 50
років ми хочемо з
А
я напевно почну пане Григорію дозволу
дуже велично ви підкресли про кадровий
потенціал про науковий потенціал про
людський капітал який наявний в Україні
я відразу школи оце проголосили
проаналізував складові глобального
індексу інновації саме за цими
показниками Україна займає високі
позиції тобто У нас є кому розробляти У
нас є для цього наявні людські ресурси і
Одним із таких показників який би міг
сказати от чого ми хочемо досягти через
певний період часу ми хочемо покращити
наші позиції щодо глобального індексу
інновацій зараз нажаль ми знаходимося у
четвертому десятку але дуже було б
чудово прекрасно для України Якби могли
перейти в інший ран і скажімо вже
приблизиться до двадцятки це дуже
складно бо тому що основна причина яку
називають наші це свого роду відсутність
державної підтримки відсутні державної у
розвитку інноваційної діяльності тому
усі зусилля наші були спрямовані на те
щоб змінити існуючу нормативно-правову
базу перевести її у відповідність до
світових вимог щодо підтримки і
Новаторів звісно Ми не можемо
гарантувати того що буде достатньо
фінансових ресурсів для того щоб усіх
інноваторів підтримати але конкурс на
засадах вона їх буде стимулювати і
мотивувати до діяльності робити свої
скажімо продукти більш
конкурентоздатними на світовому ринку на
Європейському ринку та навіть на
національному ринку створювати високий
рівень конкуренції Це ті речі що ми
хотіли б досягти чого ми хочемо досягти
щоби
інноваційної продукції в Україні який
реалізовується зростав щоб видатки на
підтримування інноваційної діяльності у
суб'єктів реального сектора економіки
підвищувалися Тому що на сьогодні на
жаль бізнес ще І зовсім достатньо
інвестує інноваційну діяльність бізнес
цікавить і розробки які можуть
переносити доходи і знову ж таки якщо це
нецікаво бізнесменові не буде оце
інвестувати а для того щоб його
зацікавити Ми також от сьогоднішніх
заходом доводимо інформацію що є цікаві
ідеї є цікаві розробки вони можуть бути
розміщені на платформі коли платформа
презентували то одне із питань на
вчорашній конференції Також я згадав про
це інструмент було таким чи доступ до
платформи є владним цей доступ є
абсолютно безкоштовним унікальний
інструмент який варто використовувати і
скористатися відразу після її запуску
платформи на національному рівні дякую
А хочете я дав ми на насправді
основний момент комунікаціями вчора теж
конференцію тому що ми про це вчора дуже
багато говорили як комунікувати як
зрозуміти що у нас дійсно є ці науковці
і як бізнесу знайти цих науковців де
вони де вони знаходяться тому що навіть
знають практики Коли ти
їдеш який проводити захід будь-яку
область України і там у тебе на заході
зустрічаються люди які живуть в одному
місті бізнесу науки і кажуть у вас
цікаві розробки ми хочемо з вами
працювати Ну ти розумієш що Щось тут не
так працює воно можливо якось по
інакшому працювати на рівні області Але
якщо процес зрушується з міста то це
дуже добре насправді і один момент ще я
хочу згадати вчорашній приклад Сербі
свою стратегію у реалізації на
національному рівні спеціалізації на всю
країну країна невелика просто і
вони своїй стратегії смерть
спеціалізації по суті це другий рік коли
вони її втілюють вони її презентували
дуже активно на весь Європейський союз
тому числі була дуже велика презентація
стратегії смак спеціалізації і вони
говорили що вони за два роки еее завели
150 мільйонів з різних джерел
фінансування саме пріоритетів своєї
стратегії фінансування дуже різне і
науковців це фінансування
інфраструктурних інфраструктурних
проектів але це в основному фінансування
міжнародних донорів і я нагадаю що
Сербія немає доступу до структурних
фондів Європейського Союзу Тобто це це
можуть бути й вісей це може бути інші
європейські фонди які нам доступні також
і тут момент комунікації що себе змогли
залучити як вони змогли залучити і вони
про комунікувати що нас є ці пріоритети
що є науковці дослідники що ми готові
співпрацювати Таким чином будується
партнерство між іншими регіонами
Європейського Союзу і налагоджується
співпраця але тільки Коли тебе побачить
можна зробити це партнерство інакше ми
просто Невидимий для для інших
Може я дозволю собі так трошки
підсумувати цю дискусію
Мені б хотілось щоб скажімо будь-хто з
нас або будь-хто з українців років через
небагато кількість
якщо зустріне когось з іноземців то щоб
про Україну казали що це інноваційна
країна так наприклад як ми можемо зараз
сказати там про Сінгапур Або можливо там
по південну Корею то можливо якась така
від на Мета може стояти
перед інноваційною сферою
і щоб
можливо кожен український вчений кожен
українець український підприємець якщо
він має ідею він мав можливість цю ідею
здійснити в Україні створити продукт і
досить просто вивести цей продукт на
будь-який ринок чи то український чи то
європейський та азіатський
чи то будь-який інший тож якщо хтось
захоче додати вас є така можливість
я хочу ще додати одну річ контексті того
що пані Надія згадувала про Сербію і про
те що в них є визначені пріоритети Та у
нас прийнято законопроект який визначає
пріоритети наукової науково-технічної та
інноваційної діяльності уряд схвалив
законопроект що також відкриває нові
певні можливості для усіх науковців і
Новаторів і принципі ми знаємо що
відбувається фінансування із урахуванням
пріоритетів це також в один із елементів
які сприятиме покращенню фінансуванню у
2022 наступному роках
наших планів і бажання дуже важливо щоб
не знали про наші стартапи інновації
потужні наукові розробки в Україні але і
дійсно у світі а це все залежить від
популяризації і рівня його виходу тому
що ми зараз нарешті це нарощуємо
наприклад позитивний приклад недавній
буквально українських стартапів
встановив національний рекорд по
безперервному пітчинг у стартапів тобто
111 Це була трансляція і це теж хороший
захід наразі також вони випустили книжку
20 кращих стартапів українських було
дуже круто якби там на наступні три роки
ми змогли вже випустити книжку 200
кращих стартапів і також їх о диво
популяризувати і демонструвати їх світі
і таким чином ми могли залучити
міжнародних партнерів до виконання
проектів в Україні але це також
пов'язано з нарощуванням потужностей
інфраструктури зокрема не тільки новації
але й дослідницької ми вже про це
сьогодні говорили Тому це теж дуже
важливі взаємопов'язані питання тоді все
було б дійсно круто Не забувайте
цікавий конкурс у 2022 році це цей такий
цікавий конкурс який запровадженням
указом Президента в Україні куди Ми
запрошуємо інноваторів із цього світу і
паралельно зараз завершується фінал
конкурсу IQ у місті Харкові який за
підтримки Міністерства освіти і науки
України проводить компанія Sigma
Software там у нас сьогодні борються за
краще
ysoft Таким чином і Новатор в Україні
працюють дуже активно do та ініціативно
і не думаю що це остання ініціатив у
сфері діяльності в Україні
для розробки
фінансових і нефінансових ресурсів які
можуть підтримати науковців бізнес
інфраструктуру в області і таким чином
якщо науковець заходить в робочу групу
по Smart спеціалізацію себе в області
Він має можливість саме свій стартап
саме свою ідею a7x закласти тобто таким
чином він його і підтримує і це не
тільки
важливість важливість того що це
фінансові ресурси будуть але це ще буде
унікальна можливість для того щоб знайти
саме і в області і за за межами області
своїх партнерів в у Дякую колеги
ми поговорили про інновації і що цікаво
у нас наступна тема сьогоднішньої
дискусії буде стосуватись жінок в науці
і жінок не тільки в науці та жінок Yves
інноваціях
тому я хочу подякувати
нашим спікером
за ідеї за інформацію яка стосується
цієї теми І запросити для подальшої
дискусії
наших гостей
ми будемо говорити про
преміювання Юнеско для жінок в науці ми
будемо говорити про питання гендерної
рівності про один також пріоритетів
інтеграції України до Європейського
дослідницького простору в
А
я хочу нагадати що
[музика]
дорожня карта інтеграції
України до Європейського дослідницького
простору
в рамках цього пріоритету містить
конкретні досяжні показники над якими
працює зараз Міністерство освіти і науки
України і
для досягнення цих показників
для
реалізації тих ідей які
містить дорожня карта активно
долучаються й
і представники
українського та міжнародного
бізнесу та підтримують окремі
конкурси які стосуються
питань в тому числі гендерної рівності
тощо Я запрошую зараз еее до нас
приєднатись
Катерину спеціаліста з корпоративних
комунікацій компанії Лореаль Україна в
у
Марину саприкін у голову правління
громадської організації центр розвитку
КС в
Ірину Сулим кандидат хімічних наук
старший дослідник цю старшого наукового
співробітника інституту хімії поверхні
ім чуйка Національної академії
наук України
доктор фізико-математичних наук
заступницю директора з наукової роботи
інституту математики Національної
академії наук України
переможницю премії Лореаль Юнеско для
жінок у науці у
2018-19
тож Хто з вас хоче почати цю дискусію
хочу розказати свій досвід свої ідеї і у
Доброго дня всім
Я представляю
комунікації корпоративні в компанії
Україна по-перше дуже дякуємо запрошення
це велика гордість для нас сьогодні
показати досвід бізнесу як семи
долучайтесь до та підтримки жінок у
науці та підвищення рівня
представленості їх науці Я думав що
пішли з презентацією про премію про
глобальну та про премію в Україні
попрошу виступи статті на екран і
детально розкажу А про особливості
записку Привіт на глобальному рівні
спільно з ЮНЕСКО в Україні і далі вже я
думаю що наші наш партнери наші учасниці
і вже так розкажуть більш детально про
їх досвід
і так в
а
компанія Лореаль і вже понад сто років і
насправді історично так склалось що
компанія виступає за розширення прав та
можливостей жінок і у 1998 році групи
Лореаль а саме фундація Лореаль це
окрема структура а окрема організація в
компанії спільно з Юнеско об'єднали
зусилля з метою а
збільшення представленості жінок науці і
насправді ж за 23 роки ми вже маємо
3800 жінок які отримали відзнаку завдяки
цій премії і далі я розкажу в більш
детально у яких напрямах Пристав вона
прийме на глобальному рівні Отже а один
з напрямів це підтримка студенток та
школярок віком від 13 до 18 років з
метою заохочувати їх щоб вони обирали
професію і відповідно підвищувати рівень
писемності
у науці адже вони стикаються насправді з
дитинства з стереотипом з упередженнями
всі про них знаємо що
філологія лише для жінок що математика
для жінок і тд тобто
Саме ці напрям він покликаний боротися з
цим стереотипом
наступна форма а премій на глобальному
рівні А яка в принципи реалізуються
багатьох країнах світу це національний
премії Отже її ми запускали 18-му році
спільного а засновник Академії Наук
ЮНЕСКО в Україні а а ось трошки згодом
про премію в Україні а пізніше наступною
формою
є міжнародні молоді таланти коли серед
серед переможниця національних премій
журі подають кандидати на міжнародному
рівні обирають топ-15 ааа переможниць і
всі вони є місцями кожна з них у грошову
винагороду у розмірі 15 тисяч євро
можливість
бізнес-школи Франції та церемоній
нагородження у Парижі скоро буде
церемонія у березні наскільки я пам'ятаю
а тому ми звісно в силу пандемії вона
була перенесена декілька разів але ось у
березні
наступного року нарешті Так нас буде
можливість в безпечних умовах відзначити
а переможниць міжнародної премії
попередніх років і останні напрям це
глобальна при Мілорад яка передбачає
відзнаку 5 жінок по одній жінці з
кожного континенту та всього п'ять жінок
за видатні та визначні досягнення в
науці А які змінюють або галузь або
певні певний певний прогрес в країні або
регіоні в якому який представляється
учасниця і того що становить 100 у євро
ось безпосередньо
Вибач на цьому екрані переможець
глобальної премії
цього року а також
можеш сказати що за попередні роки є
такий досвід що жінки і віком за 90
років отримували цю премію тому ми Якраз
сьогодні той щоб розділити всі ці
стереотипи
А я ж сказала що за 20 років існування
премії понад 3800 жінок отримали
відзнаку від Лореаль та Юнеско і п'ятеро
з них вони є вони стали так і її на
близьким рядками Як ви пам'ятаєте в
цьому році не було жінок серед
нобелівських лауреатів Нажаль Але
минулого року були і Ось перед вами
професором більша пенсія та Дженніфер
які є учасницями і лауреатка ми
глобально Юнеско жінок науці і вони
отримали у новому році
Нобелівську премію в галузі хімії за так
званій еее
це такий механізм що здатна змінювати
людські гени ось Тому нам є чим пишатися
і що вже п'ять жінок які взяли участь в
премій вони становлять тому вважаємо що
це вже
про прямі в Україні будь-яка соціальна
ініціатива вона повинна опускатися в
країні якщо є певний соціальний контекст
якщо є потреба як її потенціал і
відповідно в Україні Ми побачили цей
потенціал адже не було подібних премій в
Україні Так ми побачили потенціалу в
премії сьогодні також бачимо потенціал
для розвитку привів тому що в мене ми не
будемо зупинятися на досягнутому премій
будучі далі розвиватись Отже ми
запустили прямі в Україні у 8 у цьому
році спільного Академії Наук Україні з
нашим партнером
для подачі заяв так
і з березня по червень приблизно три
місяці триває прийом заяв ось
обов'язково повинні учасниці Передайте
всім критеріям які визначені на нашому
вебсайті
це критерії біля до яких вони можуть
Приймати участь в Україні запустили
форму премії отжаться прийме направлена
на підтримку молодих жінок науковець
віком від 18 до 40 років з метою
підтримати і стимулювати залишатись
науці так і розвивати науку в країні Ось
і
відповідати певним критеріям
також це наявність наукового ступеню не
обов'язково докторська ні але так
ступінь передбачається
громадянка України
внесок у популяризацію науки а також а
посилання на
публікацію міжнародних наукометричних
базах далі наші почесні члени журі А це
видатні науковці цієї країни
еее вони перевіряють відповідність всім
критеріям по всім учасницям
еее і формують таку такий шорт-лист
таблицю вже де на дивна
дає в нас 30 учасниць і вже проводять
голосування обирають топ-10 переможниць
так підсумовуються бали по кожній
учасниці і так ми маємо топ-10 почорнілі
тобто і
після цього в жовтні ми провели
інтерв'ю з кожною фоткою
співбесіди
запитання-відповіді ми дізналися більше
про їх здобутки і тд і вже після
співбесід журі обирає а також анонімно
голосуючи і за підсумками балів ми вже
маємо трьох лауреатом Отже після цього
на церемонії нагородження ми оголошуємо
імена топ-3 переможниць кожна з якої
отримує 150 тисяч гривень а грошову
винагороду на цьому екрані ви бачите
нагороджених наших лауреатів за минулі
роки Ось і вже незабаром 21 грудня о
17:00 готелі fairmont ми оголосимо імена
а переможниця четвертого вже сезону
української премії Лореаль Юнеско для
жінок науці ось тому Ми
залишаємо
сторінку в Фейсбуці щоб ви могли
приєднатись до онлайн-трансляція
церемонії і ми вже з нетерпінням
очікуємо
найочікуваніших подій у цього року Дякую
дякую
[музика]
а
також перемогла увійшла в топ-15
міжнародної премії міжнародні молоді
таланти і зараз Олена ванній avaya член
нашого журі а також яка входить топ-10
вже нашого четвертого сезону премії Ось
і також Марина саприкіна ю І так я бачу
що вже підключили до Копач Ольги
Дякуємо Доброго дня Ольга в у Доброго
дня
може ви розкажете свій досвід участі в
цьому конкурсі Як ви до нього потрапили
еее які були емоції
Чи ви
бачите
можливо якусь різницю в показниках
діяльності
своєї власної з іншими учасницями ну
площу в
А
давайте золів так а
у
Доброго дня ще раз
дякую за запрошення і насправді Це був
присутній на такі
підприємства тому що
більше звикли спілкуватися
а не для
загального
загальної і
з пояснень
стосовно
наукового процесу
насправді
дуже важливо і я подавалася в
ти і я вийшла
краще
Це було б
і це дуже важлива тому що
це допомагає тобі зрозуміти наскільки ж
в
наступний раз коли я подивилася на
премію у 2020 році
стала переможницею в
у і
ключовим результатом цього цієї Перемоги
для мене особисто в
не було була можливість говорити про
наше дослідження у.о.
і багато
популяризації
додати більш детально так і в
і дуже важливо на суспільства
роблять
необхідні для держави в
у кіно
А я безпосередньо забувай медичними
дослідженнями я фізіолог і
У нас є кілька наукових напрямів
найголовніший власне привернув увагу
забезпечив перемогу
дослідження механізмів в
А то це важлива Можливо
на
сьогоднішній день в
і не тільки для України а й для всього
світу і
[музика]
з
науковцями цікавляться тільки коли
відбувається
Скажіть будь ласка в
о.в.
у Доброго дня всім
Я школи зацікавилася кандидат хімічних
наук зацікавилася самої школи мені
завжди було цікаво
пізнавати нове проводити досліди ще
потім вступила до Прикарпатського
національного університету ім Стефаника
закінчила його і наукової роботи Почала
займатися четвертого курсу університету
тоді опублікувала свою першу наукову
працю з керівником магістерської роботи
Коли захищала свій диплому комісії був
присутній один професор який він
був головним науковим
співробітником інституту
хімії поверхні Національна академія наук
України і запросив мене вступити в
аспірантуру Так я потрапила в Київ в
аспірантуру за три роки закінчив
аспірантуру і захистив у відповідний т у
поставлений і далі продовжував займатися
наукою
створювати свій власний науковий
напрям в рамках
10 років також займає посаду
а також
поширення інформації і
у гранти куди можна подаватися куди
можна де можна отримати додаткове
фінансування на реалізацію своїх
наукових
проектів буквально
5 8 це більш доступну медіа доступно в
інтернеті ніж колегами вже якось іде
обмін
інформацією
Таким чином
Особисто я проходила стажування в різних
країнах в рамках різних
різних проектів програмі відповідно в
А чи можу чи не можу я бути податись але
вже наступного року 19-му році я подала
відповідно документи співбесіду
проходила потроху авто 10 то три сезони
підряд
19 потрапляє в топ-10
з ким бажанням ентузіазмом потрапити
розумію що сьогоднішні результати
невідомі Так можливо в.і.
а менша кількість людей вступає подає в
аспірантуру документи тобто менше
цікавляться наукою чому це все фінансова
сторона тому що після закінчення
верстатів люди хочуть студенти хочуть
іти
приватний сектор компанії зразу їм
пропонують відповідно два рази вищу
зарплату ніж цеї стипендія аспіранта
інституті Тобто потрібно щоб від
відповідно
потім я можливість коли ж людина
вступила в аспірантуру є можливість
показати їм
донести інформацію про можливість і що
наука це не тільки лабораторія
теоретичні розрахунки це ж у вільний
політ політ творчості це
комунікації це поїздки тому що це
міжнародні конференції тренінги семінари
безліч можливостей
можливість також реалізувати свій проект
отримати додаткове фінансування
стажування за кордоном Тобто це все
потім процесів дізнається і вони мають
інформації Головне щоб вони потрапили
і продовжили свій шлях і свою кар'єру
науці стосовно гендерної рівності
Особисто я можу сказати що в мене не
було перепон реалізації себе як
спеціаліста всі галузі
не зустрічалася тобто
працювала і досягала своєї мети і далі
продовжувати
дякую о
А хто хоче взяти мікрофон як я можу
доповнити щодо питання да відсотків
взагалі
я працюю в інституті математики у нас
зараз тридцять відсотків жінок і якщо ви
порівняйте це там 10 років тому це дуже
гарний відсоток Я знаю що в деяких
іноземних установах математичних це
відсоток менше і у нас зараз більше
дівчат
відсотковому
але
мабуть цікаво вам почути що
серед
сягає лише 10 з Ну а якщо ви візьмете
якісь вищі керівні органи
тому ви можете
рівність тобто воно покращується з
кожним роком але ми ще маємо багато
працювати для того щоб досягти гендерної
рівності в науці якщо процитувати
дорожню карту інтеграції до
Європейського дослідницького простору то
у нас показник досягнення цілі стояв
такий на початку року з це в сфері
досягти тридцять відсотків присутності
осіб будь-якої статі тому що ми
розуміємо Якщо говорити про систем тут
може бути одна сторона Питання якщо
говорити непростим то може бути інша
сторона питання наприклад вчора
еее мені казали про проблему наявності
чоловіків в українських школах
викладачі кому складі тут є а інша
сторона ну при якому сьогодні можливо не
говоримо але
це питання дивитись з іншого боку
[музика]
активності Яка ваша організація робить
але сьогодні
ми змогли побачити обличчя українських
науковців науковець і це надзвичайно
важливо тому що
ми хотіли б щоб вони ставали рольовими
моделями для дівчат в школах і саме для
цього ми спільно організовуємо
такі зустрічі наших науковець дівчатами
зі шкіл для того щоб вони популяризували
науку і ви знаєте точно що мене є мрія
щоб портрети наших надихаючих жінок
лауреата ІІ у на листок премії вони були
в школах в кабінетах математики фізики
хімії
які готові розказувати про дівчат які
готові зустрічатися з дівчатами а хочу
сказати і Можливо якщо нас дивляться
науковці то ми дуже заохочуємо
подаватись і мені здається що приклад
Ірини яка подавалася три рази і це
дійсно викликає таку повагу тому що ми
знаємо що іноді дівчата говорять
подалась 1 рік і там новий грала і не
хотіла би подаватися але ми а просто
говоримо дівчатам працюєте і якщо вони
підвищують там індекс Хірша працюють
наукові роботи то абсолютно Логічно що
вони можуть увійти в топ-10 В нас дуже
багато є а лавра так які стали
переможцями
які подавались вона спочатку ми
знаходили потім вони ставали топ-3 тому
що за цей рік вони зробили неймовірно
роботу над собою в контексті розвитку
своїх наукових знань і це ми відмічаємо
наше жирів відмічає хотіла б сказати що
самі завжди говорять що в нас абсолютно
відкрийте абсолютно
транспорт
і Олена якраз Мені здається що це також
приклад коли Олена стала лауреат кою
потім Вона виграла для молодих талантів
і потім запросили в жирі для того щоб
вона побачила і
зараз Олена оцінює і Для нас це велика
честь тому що це історія про те як можна
досягати дуже багато і ця премія Вона
дійсно про популяризацію науки вона вона
про те що наукою можна займатися що
Лореаль може а допомогти з якимось
такими важливими речами в контексті
своїх премій і ми знаємо що До речі дуже
класний факт що Практично всі дівчата
які в нас виграють стають лауреатами і
фіналістами Вони захищають докторка ми і
це також важливий
допомагає стати Doctor Doctor
але ще важливо сказати
яка стала переможницею першого року але
історія Марії вона настільки вразило
пройшло вже 4 роки я до сих пір це
згадую тому що коли вона розказувала До
речі а вона була онлайн всі були тоді
Offline Вона була онлайн не змогла
приїхати і вона Розказувала що вона там
подавалась
науковий журнал і вона проводила досліди
і це там два-три роки для того щоб
провести дослід для того щоб захистити
результат
журнал і вони дають рецензію що вони все
неправильно робили і Уявіть собі що
Марія з командою починає все переробляти
заново і Для нас це також було про те що
ніколи не потрібно здаватись що це
дійсно така Наукова мужність
хоробрість і
тоді вона була кандидат і через рік вона
приїхала на нагородження сказала я
докторка завдяки тому числі не завдяки
Але в тому числі допомогли Тому це дуже
класна І я дуже дякую компанії Лореаль
за цю премію і за те що ви робите
популяризації науки серед дівчат
Дякую ми говорили про
те що
Україна зараз стримує до
реалізації принципів відкритої науки
тощо тому я сподіваюсь що Українські
науковці отримувати свої результати і
розміщувати їх відкритому доступі
отримувати відкриті ліцензії
gnu і думаю що в
у найближчі роки ми отримуємо серед
жінок які ми бачили Тут на екрані з
кожного континенту які перемогли в цьому
світовому конкурсі хоча б одну Українку
так і в цьому сенсі вас ваша активність
Буде нам
допомагати
ще один випадок
І наступного року всі математики хотіли
не подаватись тому що за теорією
ймовірності
Вони проти цих теорій
Я думаю що ви можете навіть
переграти теорії ймовірностей Якщо таке
станеться 34 рази підряд
зможете довести
математикам про те що
теорії ймовірностей не завжди а працює
під час
адекватної оцінки роботи тих чи інших
наукових колективів чи
окремих
дякую
Скажіть будь ласка на вашу думку взагалі
чи існує у нас в науковій сфері
проблема гендерної рівності в
у режимі вільного мікрофону
згадував розмові сьогодні на особистому
прикладі що я не зустрічалося тобто якщо
ти спеціаліст своєї області в а то в
принципі
такого відношення до тебе немає може
представляти свої роботи
з такими
досягненнями і твої роботу тебе будуть
поважати як спеціалісти сприймати
серйозно
області мене
досить
тісні контакти з різних країн
університетів жінками і чоловіками
професора ми співпрацюємо пишемо статті
робимо дослідження щоб сказати навіть
коли наприклад там питання стоїть
співавторства або порядку співавторства
Тобто нема таких
а
як сказати
від коду залежить наприклад атестат у
співавторстві немає там чоловік жінка З
якої ти країни тобто відходи йде
відповідно співавторство свої статті
можливостям інше
досвід
Я хотіла б сказати що
все дуже індивідуально І дійсно багатьом
жінкам може не пощастить і вони можуть
отримати якогось наукового керівника
секси стада наприклад Скажімо так Так що
я не думаю що тут можна казати щось
взагалі дуже різні випадки
але ще хотілося б сказати про гендерну
рівність ці питання дуже піднімалися в
науковій спільноті саме у часи наприклад
Чи можемо ми досягнути гендерної
рівності в науці поки у нас немає
гендерної рівності вдома тому що багато
науковець вони жаліли ся що під час
повідомлений мають більше навантаження з
дітьми більше навантаження з домашньою
роботою і таке інше
еее тому
також зазначають Я входжу представляє
Україну в спільноті європейський жінки в
математиці і також там піднімаються теми
в
у вкладу жінок в науково
організаційні питання жінки зазвичай
більш
активні і займаються організацією більше
наукових конференцій роботі з молоддю і
статистично так виходить що коли чоловік
і більше зосереджуються на науці жінки
беруть на себе багато ще знаєте
організаційних питань і потім дуже важко
порівнювати науковий вклад і наукові
результати І навіть нещодавно було
досить цікаво у мене була дуже хороша
докторська з великої кількості
публікацій Але нещодавно
еее мені колега один сказав знаєте у
того чоловіка ще більше публікації
означає засміялася і сказала що я
здогадуюсь що своїх двох дітей він не
годував так як їх тут питання у дивитись
дуже
різних сторін От і я пропоную не
забувати ніколи що у нас є Поки що немає
гендерної рівності вдома в багатьох
жінок в мене є тому я докторка і
заступниця директора
гадаєте чи треба в законодавстві чином
визначити якісь конкретні аспекти
Мент відмінності можливо які стосувались
саме жіночої або чоловічої статі
знаєте Я
завжди задам
порівняння наукових результатів там
нібито я проти квотування в науці Але я
вважаю що мають бути якісь просто
зроблені для жінок на законодавчому
рівні
Заходи які полегшать їхню роботу в науці
тобто для жінок які пішли наприк і
декрети гнучкий робочий час замість
декрету без
оплати їхньої праці тому що багато жінок
науковець вони саме вдома можуть писати
свої наукові статті і тобто виключати їх
цього процесу це якби не не гарно От і
Тобто мають бути створені різноманітні
допоміжні заходи знову ж таки по досвіду
європейських жінок математиці Я бачу що
на заході цим займаються вони створюють
можливості щоб на конференції були
спеціальні люди які зможуть доглянути
дітей щоб жінки могли приїхати з дітьми
на цій конференції звісно і нам треба до
цього прямувати на законодавчому рівні
так
наприклад дитячих садочків Що Україна
повинна також прийняти цей досвід
академічних установах та в
у
дитячі садочки для працівників Академії
Наук України бо взагалі питання дитячих
садків Україні не вистачає місце це
будуть такі створені дитячі садочки на
при організації Академії Наук Це буде
дуже великим
полегшенням для роботи жінок науковець і
стосовно
гендерної рівності кількості часу жінка
приділяє своїй родині сім'ї недавно
[музика]
інформацію що американські вчені провели
статистику 23 роки свого життя жінка
присвячує родині
23 роки оскільки науці
залежності від того хто скільки проживе
і стосовно гнучкого
графіку роботи
тому що Я особисто в декрет не
повністю тобто я працювала
16-ий рік 2 декрету так само тобто був
було напрацювання експериментальної
частини і під час
декрету що написання статей публікацій
Тобто це дуже
важливо в
і дякую
не хоче хоче додати Ну я думаю що
можна подивитись коли запитали про
гендерну рівність можна подивитись
скільки в нас жінок а які входять члени
Президії Національної академії наук
і
друга жінка була обрана а одна з них
співголова і по-друге мені здається тоді
ще одне питання це оплата
науковець ми знаємо що вона не дуже
високо якраз минуле не говорила але я
нещодавно спілкувалася своєго лежанкою і
вона спілкувались цей час зі своїми
колегами європейського університету і
там Щоб страйк через різницю В оплаті
між чоловіками та жінками а тому можливо
тут потрібно розглядати і контекст
декрету так Тому що жінки і Іра можливо
виключення але все ж таки
ці роки вони втрачають А
коли чоловіки пишуть роботи а по-друге
це все ж таки дуже мало жінок в
керівництві і третя це оплата праці в
у Дякую тож я думаю що ми можемо на
цьому еее дискусію
організаторами та фіналістами преміальні
Юнеско для жінок науці
закінчити давайте закінчимо на позитивні
позитивно та ще 21 в нас буде
нагородження української премії для
жінок у науці і можна долучатись до
фейсбуку компанія Лореаль в у Фейсбуці і
можна дивитись цю церемонію вперше ми
робимо її відкритою можна подивитися
можна одразу дізнатися хто ж став трьома
лауреатка
дякую о а отже з нами була пані Катерина
Марина саприкіна Ірина
Олена і
ми говорили про жінок науці про гендерну
рівність і по суті про
можливості досягнення
тих показників які зазначені в
пріоритеті чотири дорожньої карти
інтеграції до Європейського
дослідницького простору
на цій дискусії наш сьогоднішній день
присвячені присвячений науці та
інноваціям підходить до завершення
Можливо я хотів би підвести
трохи підсумків
і згадуючи и
А ти питання ті проблеми які сьогодні
обговорювалась представниками наукової
інноваційної сфери представниками
бізнесу з представниками громадськості
хотів би
сказати еее такі речі ну по-перше ми
цього року досягли
у значного прогресу в
а по результатам діяльності
і не тільки Міністерство освіти і науки
України
наукових установ закладів вищої освіти в
цілому сфері по досягнення зазначених
цілей які визначені в дорожній карті
інтеграції науково інформаційної
системи до Європейського дослідницького
простору
Міністерства освіти і науки України
розробила
цілий ряд законопроектів
у
нормативно-правових актів які
дозволяють нашій системі Швидше
інтегруватися до
країн Європейського Союзу і ті завдання
які перед нами поставлені у 22 році
колектив Міністерства освіти і науки
України в Ти
готовий виконувати І в рамках проектів і
планів роботи на 22 рік
вони нами вже визначені Я хотів би
подякувати
своїм колегам за організацію цього
заходу
Хотів би запросити всю нашу наукову
спільноту до спільної роботи в рамках
робочих груп в рамках інших активностей
які присвячені миті це інтеграції
України до Європейського дослідницького
простору
сказати вам дякую допобачення і
доступних
у заходів Міністерства освіти і науки
України в
о.в.